wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some amazing
motivation
from ed my let enjoy
[Music]
i can't tell you why i'm this way but i
do believe it was baseball i never took
it personally when a coach said
you're dropping your shoulder in other
words because of athletics when a guy
said spread your right leg out your legs
are too close together never thought
i suck i can't hit i wanted to know how
to hit better
i wanted to know how to throw better and
so for me
personally i'm constantly in a crisis to
get to the next version of me it's not
like i'd like to
i wish i only would like to i probably
have a little bit more peace in my life
i am in a crisis to get the next version
of me and so
the guy sitting in front of you right
now if i come back in a year and i'm
just the same exact person with the same
thoughts same ideas same ways of
delivering them
this was a wasted year of my life right
so i want to
know how to get to that next version of
me and so for those of you that struggle
with taking criticism
i got to ask yourself how important is
it to you to grow because you were put
on earth to grow to contribute to serve
to help you were in your way and the
current version of you
is perfect as it stands right now but it
will be inferior next year
you're perfect as you are now especially
you ladies listening to this
there's all this messaging you're not
this you're not smart enough women are
too dominant then they're a diva right
or
you're not beautiful enough ladies men
you too you are perfect as you exist
right now but that version of you isn't
sufficient next year you got to be crazy
hungry crisis
to get to that next version of you i
want the data i want the input
i want the information i want the
feedback to get to the next version of
me regardless of how it emotionally
makes me feel i'm like driven by that
without that information why am i living
if i could go back and you could only
give me one skill to begin with and i
had to build from all of it
i can tell you for sure what it would be
for me and that would be the ability to
influence
so it's the ability to persuade people
without that skill set the vast majority
of my wealth does not exist if you can't
persuade people
if you can't influence people to make
decisions that are in their own best
interest but that also
grow your business your brand your
company your net worth you can't ever
become successful
one thing that everybody i know that's a
leader and everything they do can do is
persuade people now
i watch people do that in all different
types of ways some do it through
intimidation some through do it through
force
some do it through humor some do it
through persuasive strategies
transfer of energy you name it but all
leaders can persuade
all successful people can get people to
make decisions in their own best
interests
that also get them to participate with
their company it's the number one skill
that i see most people not spending the
most time on is their ability to
communicate
their ability to persuade people and
because they're constantly trying to go
to a different course or they think that
somehow if their product is good enough
or they get the right
sales pitch that somehow they're going
to win don't go broke trying to look
rich
that's one thing everybody's doing right
now they're getting broke trying to look
rich
so here's what i am i don't care where
you put the money you know there's guys
that are saying should be real estate
should be the stock market
if you don't save money when you're
broke this is the thing no one's telling
you
if you don't save money when you're
broke i'm talking about 10 bucks a month
20 bucks a month the crazy belief system
in the world is
that you will save it once you make more
if you have a habit of spending
you will spend more when you make more i
know a
lot of people who make a lot of money
who have
a lamborghini or a car or a house that
are dead
broke dead broke you all would be
shocked by who's really rich and
by who's really broke yeah you'd be
shocked because you either are a spender
or you are a saver
when i was 26 years old i made 750 000
that year and i was living in a 750
a month apartment i love the book by my
brother evan carmichael built to serve
you guys this is the kind of thing you
get in this book
most people wake up and drive to a job
they hate think about your five closest
friends
are they happy do they live their lives
with purpose do you
we put on a fake front for what we want
people to see and think about us
but the reality is most people aren't
happy we're lost we settle
you can't be happy if you don't know
your purpose and then he goes on to
explain how to do that
you guys should get this book built to
serve by my dear friend evan carmichael
so there's this governor on our lives
and it is a governor and it's a it's
your identity it's this internal it's
what you think you're worth
it's what you think you deserve and the
problem for good people see
we all know someone right now in our
life or we have who's not
ethical who's not a good person who's
winning and you're like i can't believe
they're getting it right
why can't i i'm a good person i treat
people well i'm honest
here's the reason why by the way the
unethical person eventually
karma you reap what you sow comes home
to ruse but if you're a good person this
is so important people understand this
because it took me a long time a good
person in any endeavor
will only take from it what they think
they deserve
what they think they're worth in other
words if there was a pizza here you're a
good person you don't take all 12 pieces
right a good person thinks there should
be an equitable distribution
bigger so i might take seven or eight
you know and i would arm wrestle you for
it
but long story short what is is that you
a good person will not take more from
the table of life than they think
they're worth or they think they deserve
and so you have this governor on your
identity so what happens is our it's
like a thermostat our lives get going
we start doing really well if we're a 75
degree and our life gets to 85 and 90
degrees
unconsciously we go we don't know we're
doing it
we start to cool life back down to get
it back to where we're comfortable
the reverse is also true when things
start to go really bad and you're broke
and you're struggling
you find a way to heat your life back up
to what you think you're worth and you
deserve so
the way we alter our life is sure we
gotta alter our behavior and our
relationships and our circumstances but
the only way it's permanent
is that we alter that governor that
thermostat and we start to believe we're
worth 85 degrees of life 95 degrees of
life 110 degrees of life
and there's ways we can alter that how
do we alter it a couple different ways a
one is what you just said is that you
put yourself in circumstances
that are demanding of you past what you
think your capacity is and when you
succeed at them you build a new water
line you do
you throw yourself out there past where
you're comfortable and
you do an 85 degrees behavior and you
knock it out of the park and you go
your brain starts to believe it
repetitiously when you start doing that
you build a new line now you're 85
degrees that's number one
the second way though is association if
you're around people and whatever that
endeavor is if it's a sport you're in or
if it's a business
or your faith or your peace if you begin
to associate with people who live in
that space at a higher
temperature than you through association
you get heated up
yeah and so if you're an athlete for
example you're a 70 degree athlete
and you start training all the time with
85 and 90 degrees your identity through
osmosis goes up
if you're a person is trying to improve
their faith in their life or their
their personal peace about them you all
know this you've seen it when you start
to hang around people that
are a little bit more peaceful than you
or meditate a little bit more through
that association
over time the thermostat changes in that
area and so it's both behaving in
certain way and then your associations
trying to prove people wrong or right
about you is a cheap level of motivation
and it will wear out in other words it's
not it's not the lack of it
it's just it's not the best type people
say well hey
tom brady six round draft pick i mean
he's constantly trying to prove him that
they picked the wrong guys
i know tommy a little bit and i can tell
you that motivates him but if you think
he's become the greatest football player
of all time
because he's trying to prove people from
20 years ago wrong about where he was
drafted
you don't get elite performance tom
brady is where he is because he sets
standards for himself
and has massive goals and ambitions to
for himself not to prove other people
wrong i promise you when he's sitting
under center in the super bowl
he's not going i was a six round draft
pick that's not what moves him
yeah and so i think it's low level
motivation i do it too and the sooner
you drop
it's it's the symptom of the same
disease right so proving your family
wrong
or right is a symptom of the same
disease which is you are still obsessed
with what other people are thinking
about you and not doing things that make
you happy that enrich
you to fulfill your soul and so the
irony about spending your life worrying
about what everybody else thinks about
you here's the irony
is that those people will never be
thought about after they're dead
so they spend their life obsessing with
everyone thinks about them
only to die and have no one ever
remember them because people that are so
obsessed with what other people think
about them
never really ever fulfill their
potential so once you can drop that
addiction whether it's friends
strangers or your parents and you begin
to do things that fulfill
you that make you happy that change
other people's lives by your
contribution
now you can be remembered now your your
life echoes into eternity even if it was
a quiet life
i remember going all the work i'd put
into this
all the hopes my family and i had all
the travel ball
all the everything we did all the games
all the great plays all the errors i
made the fly ball i dropped at fullerton
you know all that stuff i was gonna get
drafted then i did all that stuff right
the guys i played with over
like a flicker man like a flicker that
crap was over and we're on that bus ride
back and i remember thinking
man i should have tried harder i should
have played
harder i should have given this more
you know this stuff guys do man you're
running sprints there's two dudes who
run
every sprint full speed and then there's
the dudes who run eighty percent six of
them you know exactly what i'm talking
about right
he's kind of cool you know it doesn't
matter i'm not the fastest guy so no one
will know when i don't win the sprints
you know those guys you know exactly
what i'm talking about right this guy
kind of
doesn't really catch the ball on his
throwing side in the outfield when his
morning catches it over he does
everything wrong
throws it back that's the thing that
costs the guy getting thrown out at
third and you lose by a run
because you just practice like that the
guy in the bullpen is kind of like not
really focused he's just kind of
getting loose right instead of just
laser focused on everything he's doing
all the time
right you don't want to leave here you
don't want it to end whether it ends in
the big leagues it ends in the minor
leagues
it ends here or you never even get on
the field this year
okay having wondered whether you gave it
all you got because it's going to
transfer into the man you become when
you leave here
and most importantly it's going to be
your identity when you get tired when
you get fatigued when you get down
when you're in a slump it's your habits
rituals routines and your standards that
carry you through
if you don't have good habits you don't
have good rituals you don't have good
routines
always in your life you will fall down
in bad times frankly
the reason that i think my stuff has
grown and i'm not trying to be
braggadocious in this regard my
content's
good like my content is stuff that could
really affect you and change you
i'm not going to tell you 1100 times to
get your money i'm not going gonna tell
you to uh
be kind eleven hundred times and just
repeat myself for
binary and all this stuff the guys just
keep repeating themselves
it's just it's mindless information i
don't even understand how they have
following to be honest with you it's
like i've heard you say this
same thing 2 000 different times whereas
i'm trying to keep my content fresh
relevant inspirational but also
strategic
that's not knocking people it's just i
think you do this very well
like if you're going to be in a space
really bring value to people
you know i mean if people are going to
follow you give them value and
inspiration for the
the privilege of them following you so i
feel an obligation to try to create
stuff
daily when i can to uh move someone's
life forward most people's will to win
is for sale
it's for sale most people's will will is
for sale to win is for sale they can be
bought
i can't be bob so if we give you just
most people if we gave me just enough
money
if there's a certain dollar amount you'd
stop working hard give you a title
you'll stop working hard we give you a
car
or a plane or a house or that's the book
bro
is that the book yeah that might be the
book that is the book so your will to
win
is for sale that's right and i decided
once i realized that because i watch it
happen with people
in their body and their finances and
their family and their faith whatever it
is i'm not for sale
so there isn't a place you're going to
buy me you can't get me there's not a
stop a place a destination where you're
going to get me to
relent to quit i want to improve that
doesn't mean i don't struggle with my
motivation from time to time yeah
it doesn't mean i don't get confused or
down of course i do but i'm not for sale
yeah you can't buy me
and you know this too we see a friends
of ours even guys in their 60s and they
sold their company for blah blah blah
and
that they golf nine days a week or
whatever you know that's fun but they're
for sale they
bought you were bought you were for sale
i'm not for sale
everything in your life happens for you
not to you i'm just a huge believer in
that and so
my baseball dream ended i had an injury
probably gave me a premature end to
occur that would have ended anyways
in hindsight because i played with
enough great players that i kind of know
there was a gap in just
god-given ability level not work ethic
but i think to be the greatest there has
to be some proclivity for it
and work ethic right and so i kind of
maxed out my
limited abilities um and so when i got
released
i ended up moving back home with my
parents i couldn't find a job i was
depressed i spent about a year at my
parents house
just broke in every way financially
spiritually
mentally physically i remember my dad
came home my dad just got sober
and my dad said to me hey i met this guy
at a meeting i got you a job you get
your ass down there tomorrow morning at
6 a.m
getting out of this house and getting a
job and i'm like okay i have a college
degree
you know i'm being picky for a year
watching maury povich reruns every day
on tv and
jerry springer i go down there at 6 00
a.m i walk in i said hey my name's eddie
my leg i'm here for the job they're like
what job
i remember this vividly right and i'm
like i don't know
um they just told me you'd know and they
go we have no idea who you are and we
don't know what the job is
they said do you know who's hiring you i
said i don't remember
and they go well then you need to come
back and i go to the door and i go wait
a minute
his name's tim they're like there's a
lot of tins and i go well
i know he must be an alcoholic because
he was at a meeting with my dad last
night
oh drunk tim we know tim right and where
i was was a place called mckinley home
for boys it was a group home
a campus of group homes all my boys were
wards of the court they were removed
from their family either because their
parents were incarcerated
killed or were molesting them and i
ended up in cottage eight
cottage eight i had twelve boys they
were seven to ten years old
and i walked through that door that
morning not even knowing what the job
was
and it transformed my life i mean in an
instant brother
i just saw these eyes these little boys
they just wanted someone to love them
and believe in them and care about them
and i'd have this big belief that
people that go through any dysfunction
in their family or abuse as a kid i
think our eyes are different
we just have these different eyes man
and so i could connect with these guys
mine wasn't as severe as theirs but i
knew what it was like to have that kind
of anxiety and that kind of stress and
that kind of pressure put on you as a
little boy
and i became like their father i was
there with them on christmas and
halloween and their birthdays and i
lived with them
and it changed my world because in that
instant i went from being this athlete
who was ego recognition
significance gonna get rich it's all
about me always when you're a good
athlete you knew this growing up was
always
accolades all of a sudden in that
incident it became about serving people
making a difference and like oh this is
what makes me happy
oh i was actually born to serve and help
people crazy
no one that never happened playing
baseball and while i worked there
two years into it the financial business
that i'm in came along
and i started in it part time and i'm
the i was the rare young businessman who
approached the business world from a
place of service
and giving and not making money and
ironically the more i serve people the
more i made a difference the more i
contributed the more i was rewarded
financially
i didn't do it for that reason but
that's what happened so that's how i got
into the business was
actually and again everything my dad
wasn't an alcoholic
he's not at that meeting i don't get
that job and if he wasn't if it wasn't
alcoholic i wouldn't have connected with
those boys
so all of that in hindsight happened for
me right and
and had i met the financial business
before that i'd have flown out of it i'd
have been about ego
making money and when that didn't happen
i'd have left and so it all happened in
the right sequence
wow i kept my job at mckinley and part
time i started in the financial services
industry and started to build a team of
people and started to get my licenses
and that transition
and i struggled like every upstart
entrepreneur does take like three to
five years until you really get a few
clients you know
not in any business i don't care if it's
financial services tech
dry cleaners all entrepreneurs the first
five years is just full of false starts
you get to go and then you don't you get
it going you take a step forward you
take three back it's constant false
starts it's constantly
thinking you have it going it's
constantly negotiating in your mind the
price you're paying is it worth it
should i quit
should i give in i'm constantly i spent
the first five years
daily contemplating quitting yeah all
the time
it wasn't fun and and even there's just
a part of you i think in anything you're
doing when you're struggling
is this really for me is this my destiny
should i be doing this and we misread
failure from some sign you know is this
a sign i shouldn't be doing it you know
is this a sign i
am you know not cut out for this instead
of looking for signs that you can win
right and so i spent the first five
years literally trying to find ways to
quit
trying to find ways to get out
struggling and struggling and struggling
and
i went broke i lost a car i had the
water turned off in my place i
you know i had a i bought my first house
i ended up having it foreclosed on
eventually so
i'm not that house with the unicorns
that you saw right or my beach place
like that's all the after people don't
realize that there were just
years and years of of grinding and
struggling and worrying in the beginning
and then
then i made some mental changes and some
shifts
that altered my life then again i knew i
wanted to be successful i think like in
most things like
they show up eventually but maybe they
don't look like the way you thought they
look when they show up
right so i was gonna be a baseball
player from the time i was a little boy
i was gonna be a major league baseball
like how young oh four or five years old
talking about that
knowing players studying it telling
people i was going to be one
looking in a certain way trying to be
athletic i'm a little dude naturally
trying to build my body up and build
myself up
well i am i mean i mean look at that but
i got little risks and i don't do
pilates but like you do but i do work
out but
but anyway and the pilates looks good on
you you look younger than i do brother
so but anyway i did i did uh
i did grow up wanting to be somebody and
then i got a mentor when i was really
young
hall of fame baseball player named rod
carew who most of you out there would
probably know grabbed me when i was a
young man and started pouring blood
how young was that i was probably nine
okay he grabbed me started pouring
belief into me
he saw me at a baseball camp saw that i
was a little guy saw that i had some
potential i kind of swung like him and
batted like him
and so i spent the better part of my
youth being mentored and coached
one-on-one by a hall-of-fame baseball
player
and he just poured baseball tools into
me he poured belief you're going to be
somebody someday you're going to do
something great so i had someone in my
ear i respected
believing in me from when i was young i
think that helped me when i'm having a
difficult time in my life in one area
another
all i have to really do is look back 60
to 90 days
and it's the behaviors i had 60 to 90
days ago
that are causing the results i get
negatively right now
and so like for example when i'm not
really you know progressing in my career
or in my
financial situation if i look back 60 to
90 days prior
i stopped reading the books listening to
the audios doing the things that grow my
identity
and i pay the price 60 to 90 days later
in my body
my body isn't looking like i want it to
if i look back 60 to 90 120 days
that's when my diet got weaker that's
when my workouts weren't quite as
intense as they were
previously and i pay the price three to
four months later
this is true in every area of our life
our lives are almost like
reading a newspaper today but we're
reading the headlines from 90 days ago
and so that's what confuses people they
see the external results of their life
but
but if you did if you read the newspaper
from 90 to 120 days ago that's where the
news was made
not today and so in every area of your
life you got it going right now you got
to fuel the fire if you've got your
business going your finances going
your relationship going your faith going
where you want it to
you have to continue to do the
activities that got you here in the
first place
because 90 days from now you're going to
read today's news
that's how it works it's a hard thing to
accept but in our lives
we are getting out of our life right now
exactly what we believe we're worthy of
exactly what we think we deserve our
life is a direct reflection
of our identity which is the thoughts
concepts beliefs values and worth we
hold true to be about ourselves
and so as hard as it is to accept we're
getting out of life right now what we
believe we're worth
and we believe we're worth it because of
these patterns and our identity
and our lack of choosing to have what we
want not just the material things
not just the body fat not just the body
weight not just
the amount of money not just having the
relationship but
choosing the emotion we want the level
above all this stuff i discuss
and the level way down here where the
people discover the basic stuff then
there's what i've been covering the
highest level
is to choose the emotions we want to
experience
and to begin to run patterns that serve
us and eliminate the ones who move us
further from them
i want you to think about something real
quick see there's a book being written
about your life
isn't there someone somewhere's taking
inventory of your life
don't compare your chapter 1 to
someone's chapter 10.
you write your own book and at any
moment in your life
you can decide that you want to make
this the new chapter you're tr
literally in your life you can turn the
page
and those previous chapters are your old
book it's like old testament new
testament
old story news story they're connected
they're related but you can flip the
page and you can have a whole new story
if you decide right now i am literally
turning my breakthrough
is i turn the page and in this second i
start
to write the best chapters of my life
you could decide to do that
i kind of grew up in that space that is
dangerous because it's like a slow
asphyxiation right i grew up what i'd
call like middle class but probably the
lower side of middle class too
so i think there's and i've told you
this i think there's an advantage
sometimes you're growing up rich because
you've got connections and you see the
right behaviors modeled maybe
when you're poor a lot of my buddies
that are successful now that were poor
they knew what they didn't want they
were fighting they learned to struggle
they grew up sooner right they didn't
they couldn't make excuses they had to
learn to be self
resilient the middle is difficult
because goods the enemy are great right
and so it wasn't horrible it wasn't like
there wasn't food on the table wasn't
like i didn't get a present on my
birthday
right so you kind of start to think
that's what life is no one in my family
ever talked about dreaming or winning or
being wealthy
same time we weren't really running from
something either so there's like there
was no stimulus
the same is when you're poor is to get
out of there the stimulus when you're
rich is to replicate it
there was no stimulus from where i'm
from and so probably the rarest
background when you meet somebody that's
successful
is the middle it's actually the rarest
that you meet somebody they're from the
middle and so
a lot of your listeners come from that
place because most people are in the
middle right and so
i'm sort of i think an example of some
of the things maybe you would need to do
to get out of that space to move from
good to some
some form of greatness in your life yeah
yeah it's comfort
right that word comfort can be a killer
right and so
that's exactly why i wanted you to to
point that out is because so many of us
do come from that and also we're maybe
existing in it right now so true
and how important is it to stretch
ourselves and to really kind of
get comfortable with discomfort you do
you need to do that malcolm x is a guy
that i've read a lot about
and malcolm x my favorite quote of
malcolm x's is that which you do not
hate
you will eventually tolerate and so
there has to be this point in your life
where
what you want is so much greater than
where you are you're in such
discomfort in other words the gap
between what you're dreaming of what
you're destined to do what you're
capable of you're
aware of it compared to where you are
that tension between the two
has a pull power to it right and so it's
dif it's important all the time that
wherever you are in life that you're
chasing that next version of you there's
this
there's this thing i'm ex just
unbelievably passionate about
that is that i have this theory that
i've told you this before but
that i think at the end of your life
there's this place you come to and i'm a
christian so i think at the end of my
life
i want the lord to go hey well done good
and faithful servant it doesn't matter
what your faith is you probably
are aware there's history being made or
an accounting
but i also think he's going to go hey by
the way this is who you could have been
i think he introduces you to the person
you are capable of becoming
i really believe that at the end of your
life you're going to get introduced to
the person you could have been you were
destined to be that he made you to be
and so i'm chasing that dude every day
i'm chasing that dude that's the pull
power for me every decision
i make the things i go through in my
life whether i'm gonna go to the gym
whether i make a phone call how i'm
gonna eat
does it get me closer to that guy
because i think the best end of a life
is well done
by the lord and and you're identical
twins with that person
the bad end of a life would be i meet
this man i could have been
and we're total strangers i mean we're
just complete opposites i know nothing
about this guy there's no familiarity at
all and it means that i went down these
easy roads i took the comfortable road
the comfortable road will never lead you
to the person you are destined to be
ever in your life and so i don't if you
don't become obsessed with chasing that
person
you end up never meeting them persuasion
anything so if you want to persuade your
children
if you want to persuade someone to take
a look at your faith if you want to
persuade someone in business if you want
to persuade someone to
help you in anything or help them in
anything
it's real simple for me monster belief
and so
you can't transfer to me that which
you're not experiencing yourself
right so you can't give me that people
are always trying to come up with the
magic word
the magic clothes the magic this and
there are words you should and shouldn't
use in persuasion no question about it
right there are think there are words
that are more effective than other words
and clearly to be successful in any
business you need to know what those
words are in your business
but the best persuaders the best
motivators the best speakers the best
physicians the best school teachers the
best parents
are incredible persuaders and what they
do is they come from a monster place of
conviction and belief that they can
transfer you to because
people respond to energy much more than
they do words they respond to what they
feel not what they hear and see hear and
see are real low level influencers
energy spirit transfer of energy is what
people respond to and so
i'm cognizant all the time of getting in
a state of total belief and certainty
about what it is that i'm going to
represent
or speaking if i'm speaking on stage
about a particular topic and then
transferring that energy into people and
that seems
generic or hokey but it's actually what
great persuaders do in fact if you're
listening to this you think of anybody
that you know
who's incredibly persuasive they may
have great words they probably do but
it's something you
feel from them right and that's the
difference between a great doctor and a
so-so doctor great doctor says here's
the prescription
you're out of here another one is it's
gonna work or not i don't know another
one you leave
their feeling that you're going to be
healed feeling you're in good hands you
feel their certainty you feel their
confidence
say when you hear a speaker if you're
buying real estate from somebody
but it's not just buying things it's a
great pastor in a church
a great person if you do tm who's taught
you tm it's their certainty it's the
energy you feel
and so for me it's always getting to i
have to really believe what i'm saying
i have to really feel it to transfer to
which is why we were talking earlier
you and i watched every successful
person that we know everyone gets
hammered man everyone gets knocked down
you get a you miss a close someone
changes their mind yeah you get rejected
in interview you
you you lose your baseball card whatever
it is
it's not whether you're getting knocked
down it's not even whether you get up
everybody eventually gets up
everybody gets up yeah it's the time
you're on your ass it's the time you
stay on the mat so what happened was
my dream got squashed instead of laying
around for six or eight months i was up
immediately
like that day off the mat now my eyes
are open your eyes are closed when
you're on the mat
yeah so the longer you stay on the mat
just because you've been defeated
you've now become blinded as you said
and it's prevented from getting any
other opportunity or blessings in your
life so the key is getting your butt
up like literally getting up and opening
your eyes again and chasing again
you're gonna get up so you might as well
do it now yeah how did you stay
motivated all the time
people ask me that all the time and the
answer is i didn't and neither did you
to become successful
the separator in life is really
important people think the most inspired
motivated person wins
nah not really it's the person who can
work on the days they're not inspired
and motivated it's what do you do when
you're not feeling great what do you do
when it's not your best day
how do you do that carries you through
is rituals and habits
so when you're fatigued when you're
tired when you're under pressure
you react reflexively and so successful
people rely on habits and rituals
not just their inspiration and
motivation level of course we're both
professionals
at being motivated and inspired but
that's not every day every minute
and so what do i do i work on the days
because my habits and rituals carry me
through
and so for me here's how i look at my my
life in my day
if i can control the first 30 minutes of
my day and the last 30 minutes of my day
i have a whole lot better chance of the
middle of my day being controlled
and so i'm a freak about the first 30
minutes of every day it's really about
the first 45 minutes
and i'm obsessive about the last 45
minutes of every single day
that gives me some illusion in my mind
and measure of control
the other thing it does it delivers to
me habits and rituals that serve me
that i do every day that are consistent
it gives me comfort
in stormy times that ocean out there is
raging at the top right now right the
waves are crashing
at the bottom of that ocean it's
completely calm at the bottom of that
ocean is the habitual part of the water
right it's the it's the part of the
water that stays the most consistent
that's why it's so calm
okay so when you see someone out of
control their emotions are up and down
all the time this is someone who is
without rituals and habits
successful people have those and so they
do and so it keeps me calm it keeps me
comfortable
this morning was very unusual number one
was the water was
unusually cold this morning uh really
cold
and the waves were huge very big waves
this morning
and both of those things made me think
about business and there's an
application for you that i wanted to
share with you
the first one was just getting into the
water this morning
it was freezing and when i had to get in
there to make a decision how do i get in
do i kind of take my time where i go my
feet in first
kind of get adapt and then come out get
adapted go back in up to my waist
get a little warmer then come back in up
to my neck you get the deal
but all that would do is extend the pain
all that does it's logical makes sense
don't go until you're ready take your
time but really all that does what does
that really do
that extends the pain and so i didn't do
that i did what the pros do
right which is what people do in every
endeavor that are champions is i ran
boom right in headlong
right into the water right you dive in
there's a shock
but then you get adapted so much more
quickly than you could possibly imagine
and then you're off to ride in the waves
well the same is true in business the
champions and everything i don't care if
it's your fitness
if it's your your family your faith you
name it
the way that you get great at something
is you dive into it and get adapted
quickly and you'll be surprised at your
ability to adapt and navigate your way
through success
the average people in everything frankly
the people who lose
are the ones who constantly take their
time they're too logical
they think well i can't do this until
i'm ready if i'm not ready i'll mess it
up
and i don't want to get it's too cold
it's too it's too freezing
but the truth is in business that's not
how it works if you go slow you're
extending the time you're in pain and
worse yet
while the champions have already dove in
got acclimated they're out there riding
their waves making progress
you're still on the shore deciding
whether you're going to get ready to get
ready
and so if you're an entrepreneur if
you're a business owner you're somebody
getting associated with my firm which is
a wonderful decision by the way
but if you're going to decide that
you've got to decide that and go
and trust the fact that you have your
instincts your background your training
your mentors the system around you
and that's true whether you're an
entrepreneur in my business or you're
one of these firms that i've spoken to
on the outside i want to encourage
all of you if you're going to get in get
into business and go
you'll be amazed at your capacity to
evolve and to adapt and to succeed
i don't believe in faking it till you
make it you know what entrepreneurism is
right it's the greatest self-discovery
process in the history of mankind
isn't it you learn more about yourself
what you don't know your resiliency how
tough you are
what your weaknesses are by being an
entrepreneur it's probably the greatest
self-discovery program in the history of
the world it's also this it's the
greatest self-improvement program with
the highest compensation package
possibly attached to it too
that's what our entrepreneur is a
self-improvement program
with massive compensation package
attached to it and that's why
too many of you are too focused on
growing your company and not focus
enough on growing you
because your company will never ever
exceed your identity or your vision
for it you got to grow you because what
will happen when it starts to grow
you'll start making unconscious mistakes
to shrink it making bad calls
getting weak getting lazy making
mistakes you're all nodding because
you've all done it because at some point
your business got ahead of you
it will never exceed your identity and
your vision because if the company
catches your vision if the company
catches your identity you're dying
dude i'm grateful that i have the money
for the plane ticket still right it's on
it's odd
how um small things i love big things i
love having my jet but it's
i make sure that i'm grateful for what
most people will think are small things
and i really
am like i'm i had some health issues
when i was younger with my heart i
am grateful many mornings i wake up my
day starts with gratitude i'm awake
many many mornings and so that's a
centerpiece of my life it's sort of
it's odd because i have all these things
in my head when i was a kid like
gratitude is sort of the antidote for
everything not good in my life
when i was small mom i was also really
undersized
so it's probably one of the reasons i
lift weights i was always the every
baseball picture i'm the kid holding the
sign in the front right
so i was small and skinny they used to
tease me eddie spaghetti you know and
i'd get bullied at school and i never
retaliated so i had that mixed with
shyness mixed with
chaos in my home which many people can
relate to
and i got to tell you that the shift for
me sports was good for me because it
gave me an out that i finally found
something that i was pretty good at
i think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest
is that when somebody helps us identify
our natural giftedness
and when i was a little boy when i got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size i was fast
i was the fast kid right i always wanted
to be fast kid and i got confidence in
baseball doing that
when i got into business i said you know
you're intense when someone points out a
gift about you that you also kind of
intuitively know to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're relentless i want i am those
things
and when someone linked those gifts to
me winning now i believed i could win
that's the other way to change identity
is when someone can link
your giftedness to the victory you'll
believe it not like you're great that's
general that's
[ __ ] but it's something you know
specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what i am good
at these things right i've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example
you're an unbelievable interviewer you
have this general
you you don't need to be the smartest
person in the room because you probably
are most of the time
and so there's a confidence no there's a
confidence that allows you to be present
when you interview me
and just listen that's different than
anyone who's interviewed me before
and so that's a natural giftedness for
you which is why there's a part of you
that kind of knows i am pretty you
wouldn't say it i
am pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way i changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and then
using them in my career using them in my
life
that shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was
i suck i'm shy i'm small i have a
screwed up family that's the weight
right the lifting off of the weight is
these are some gifts god gave me or the
universe gave me or that at least i know
i have
and i can spend my life using these
gifts now i've got hope now my identity
is changing
if you really want to be a leader okay
if you really want to affect other
people you
really truly if you authentic like you
really want to affect me here's the
bottom line
okay the bottom line real effectiveness
you cannot transfer
to me something that which you are not
experiencing yourself so you must first
experience it before you can give it to
me so if you really want to experience
energy faith
passion drive discipline achievement you
have to be experiencing it first to
authentically
transfer that to me so you can't always
eat last it can't always
you can't feed everybody else if you're
starving yeah
spiritually emotionally financially you
can't feed everyone if you're starving
jesus could do it because jesus was fed
he's jesus
you're a human being okay you're not a
deity and so you must be
fed you must be filled up before you can
fill up for everybody else
there's nothing wrong with making
mistakes there's nothing wrong with even
having problems
there's a challenge if we continue to
repeat the same mistake that causes the
same problems
and so what can i learn from this now
you're leveraging this problem
to grow now this isn't something you're
just overcoming and putting behind you
but you're using this experience and
this challenge to move in front of it
not just get it behind you there's a big
difference in that perspective what's
great about this problem
that's a difficult question to ask when
you're going through the middle of it ed
no it's not not if you build the habit
not if you begin to think like this
because what that does is it changes the
meaning to you it puts you in an
empowering state and not a disempowering
state
you've got to get hungry and you've got
to get focused and i know these sound
like basic things
but go to any area of your life you want
something right now pick the number one
thing you want to change
body money business relationship faith i
don't care what it is
pick it right now one to ten how hungry
are you
how desperate are you one to ten the
most desperate and hungry you could be
rank yourself number two how laser crazy
obsessed focused are you
on what it is you want one to ten ten
being
hyper psycho crazy obsessed focused
nothing's in your way and to the extent
you can
increase your desperation and hunger and
your obsessive focus
will be to the extent that you can
flourish because when those things
convene
and converge all of a sudden the
collaborations the people
the circumstances the breakthroughs the
insights
necessary begin to reveal themselves to
you and not only that
reveal themselves to you with momentum
and speed
at which you cannot believe you can wake
up a year and a half later
be number one in the world at something
that you didn't even know existed
before i'm a testimony to that and you
can be as well
your success is going to be predicated
more than anything
on your hunger and desperation level and
your ability to get laser focused
and eliminate the distractions in your
life
this is what makes us great and one of
the things we've not covered that is
such a
critical part of communication and maybe
more importantly even what you say
is your ability to listen to people it's
a
huge part of communication you know i've
taught you before that people don't
respond to what they hear
or see they respond to how they feel
when they interact with you
and one of the best ways to make
somebody feel good is that they feel
listened to and that they feel heard
i think being a great listener has lots
of benefits one people will like you
more
two you're going to learn more three it
takes the pressure off you
and so listening skills are so critical
what would you say is your greatest
asset skill
um i love people man i care about people
i uh sincerely do and so whether that's
yeah i mean i want to help you i want to
my
people say how do you get back to all
these people on social media or
i care you know you and i have talked
about the fact like i really
i i my intent is good man i i want to
i want to make a difference in the world
you know we're all put here for a reason
and like
it sounds hokey like i i've made a lot
of money like i'd like to make more
money but it's not really a driver for
me right you've got a bunch of homes and
that field that need it's not and it
doesn't it's not long lasting no
material
thing i've ever required was as cool as
i thought it would be
it's cool for a week or two and then all
right now what you know what right it's
empty and so
by the way i think everybody should have
a jet if they can have one everybody
ought to have a unicorn in their
waterfall everybody ought to
live oceanfront like i've been i say
this to me all the time i've been happy
rich and i've been happy poor happy rich
is better
don't let anybody tell you happy rich
ain't better than happy poor trust me
yeah it's better you and money's a
magnifier if you're a really good person
you get a bunch of money it's probably
going to magnify your generosity and
your kindness and your patience
and if you're a curmudgeon and mean and
hurt people money's going to magnify
that too
so i'd rather have a bunch of money
hands down right but it's not
uh something that drives me in my life
it doesn't fulfill me
when i was poor everywhere i went flip
the price tag
what's it cost what's the cost what's
the cost what's the cost i was
constantly negotiating
the price for everything in my life you
do that when you come from a place of
scarcity
of being poor successful people and
wealthy people
have a subtle distinction they don't
look at price they look at worth
is this worth it if you're constantly
looking at the price tag
you'll eventually relent you'll
eventually give in
stop negotiating the price it's a
freeing experience to totally commit
when you totally commit to a
relationship to a business
to your fitness to your faith it's a
freeing
powerful it's almost like removing
kryptonite from your life when you
totally commit
can you do that the people around you
it's costing too much
it's costing too much and you're going
maybe it's costing too much
you gotta start going no it's worth it
it's not the price it's the worth
it's a subtle distinction in your life
and now you've been very successful as
an entrepreneur
have you always been successful you just
said the word entrepreneur and always
successful so you know
listen to this i try to tell everybody
this
nobody listens to me i haven't met one
entrepreneur oh yeah everything i
have ever done works and they're lying
right now well they're not an
entrepreneur they've inherited something
i don't know right right because if you
if you're an entrepreneur you have not
always been successful right so from
steve jobs down all the way
and so i've had successes and then i'll
go backwards so
like most entrepreneurs there's false
start after fall start after fall start
so i would get it going then it would go
backwards i'd save some money then i'd
blow it you know my business would grow
then it would shrink
so no i've had i've had tons of
different financial events happen in my
life and actually actually
after people thought i was pretty
successful i'd become a millionaire
about 26 years old i'd become a
millionaire i was making a million
dollars a year
and i ended up losing it all and it
ended up i lost a home i lost a car
i ended up moving into an apartment i
was newly married i'll never forget this
i remember because this ocean's out
there we're looking at it right now and
yeah
i remember honestly defining moment you
i had everything turned off you have
power turned off and still survived one
thing i learned you don't want your
water turned off
and we had the water cut off so i'm
let's see here newlyweds my new and six
weeks married we're
still with you she's still with me she's
floating around here somewhere it man
she's with me yeah someone's in comedy i
know we do both high school and the same
thing
with our with our wives and long story
short we had to go every morning out of
the apartment go down to the pool
and shower outdoors and you bring our
toothbrush it was just shameful for me
mom and dad work my uh mom worked in the
home raised four kids my dad
uh worked in a bank very successful
executive in a bank
okay now did you so were you learning
something from him about
uh being an executive dressing i learned
about my dad real simple
hustle and busting ass so my dad was up
before i was up in the morning out of
the house
my dad would get home when it was dark i
watched my dad bust his tail i watched
my dad work saturday because he came and
had a couple cocktails he did for a long
time and that was probably by the way
why was coming home so late for a while
but in my mind and even after he became
sober he's
he just like a lot of men of that
generation my dad just busted his damn
tail i think it's almost a lost art form
with younger guys today right
my dad just flat busted it now he busted
it because he's just trying to provide
limiting things like food and shelter he
never thought about big things or dreams
or
getting wealthy or having influence he
just wanted to survive so this was my
dream place to live
all my life i wanted to live in laguna
beach california in three arch bay
i want to live in coeur d'alene idaho
and i want to be able to play golf out
in the beautiful desert in palm desert i
live in those dream places and one of
the reasons i live there
is because i talked about my dream early
in my life there's power
to just talking about just telling
people just putting in writing what your
dream is
and so i'm curious do this for me
comment below right here
and tell me and tell the world where
your dream place to live is what's your
dream place to live
you ever go to the movies at the end of
the movie they scroll down
like the leading characters names and
then what do they do if you keep
watching it
cab driver number two bouncer at the bar
number one you ever see those faceless
people
far too many of you in your life are
obsessed with what cab driver number two
and bouncer number one think about what
you're doing
instead of the lead characters you're
obsessed with what other people think
about you the thing that's gonna kill
your dream
is your addiction to other people's
approval and cab driver number two
he ain't gonna approve of what you're
doing at the end of your damn life he's
not going to show up in any of the
important chapters
yet you give him all this power all the
time stop giving people power
who aren't in your book do your life for
the leading character
you your spouse your children your
parents your legacy
they're the lead characters in the story
of you
of your life because the more you decide
to take control
of the narrative of the script of your
life and you live your dream
the more likely at the end of your life
you're going to meet that dude
there's a malcolm x quote that you
really like yeah tell me what it is and
why it's so powerful that which you do
not hate you will eventually tolerate
and i think that identifies most
people's lives in other words they
average becomes sort of like this slow
asphyxiation it's almost like an
anesthetic
and that over time we become kind of
immune and dulled to the average that
we're becoming i know this is true at
least for me
you probably experience it yourself too
and so over time we sort of minimize
where we're at in other words
i'm a little pudgy instead of being no
you're a fat ass right you don't magnify
the degree to which the pain
ought to be affecting you and so really
what he means in that is listen
you're going to get out of your life
what you'll accept that's really
difficult for people i think to
understand is look what you think you're
worth and what you're going to tolerate
is absolutely what you're going to bring
into your life
and what the outward part of your life's
going to look like and so i live by that
like i let myself
sort of feel the pain and the difficulty
of
of being not where i want to be and
whatever that area is whether to be my
spirituality my relationships my money
i let myself feel that pain because as
you know there's two motivators right
there's the gaining of pleasure
right wanting to go get something
chasing the dream but then there's the
avoidance of pain
and for a lot of champions that's a
pretty big driving force for them and so
at least for me i leverage
both of those things on me to get myself
to take action when i was really coming
up in business i went so broke that
powers turned off you know the phones
turned off i had my wife's car got
repo'd
you can have all that happen to you but
what you don't ever have happen is have
your water turned off
and i had the water turned off in our
apartment right when we were newlyweds
and i just remember the shame of every
morning getting up with her we'd have to
walk down the stairs to the pool
outdoors and take our shower brush our
teeth in that outdoor shower
and grab our stuff up i'd walk my new
bride up to our apartment and it was
just shameful for me you know
and so i'm grateful to live here and
this sounds corny but i just tell you
the honest-to-god truth it's not every
single morning but there are many
mornings when i pull the
faucet in the shower and the water hits
me and i'm that's where the gratitude
hits me
like it's got my water not just the
ocean back there but just literally that
you know i know what that's like to be
scared
i wasn't just broke i was scared i think
everything in our lives starts with our
body if you're a person of faith you
believe that's where your soul is housed
right and so it's the you you do
emotions
you don't just feel them you do them in
other words and you know this from
things you've learned in your life but
like
joy is an actual action not just an
emotion we feel a certain joy there's a
certain breathing a certain movement in
our body
depression and sadness is something we
do we're more hunched over
our breathing is more shallow right and
so there's a correlation between the way
you move your body
and your emotions they're directly this
is even before we get to dopamine hits
and
our nervous system being i'm just
telling you that the way you move your
body
is an emotion you do emotions and so
when you move your body you can't be in
full workout mode moving your body
running walking
jumping jacks jump rope and be depressed
they don't go together simultaneously
because your body doesn't get the
connection
i'm moving like i'm joyful i'm moving
like i'm having sex i'm moving like i'm
happy
these are all joyful states you can't be
depressed simultaneously
so the quickest way to change our
behavior our emotions in our state
is with our body great businesses those
of you that are business people
great businesses have a cult-like
following
have a religious-like following it's
something that all great movements have
apple has it the great fitness
companies that you think of any company
you know that's really flourishing has
kind of raving fans and
a level past that is almost cult-like
and religious-like followers they
believe that deeply and by the way i
don't mean that in a sacrilegious way
like they believe in it more than they
believe in god you know exactly what i
mean when i say that
deep raving fans and those followings
are led by
evangelists all great business people i
think all great dads all great
moms should be evangelical about their
family all great business leaders should
be evangelists constantly touting
the greatness of your family the
greatness of where you're going the
greatness of your company
are you willing to do the ugly by the
way do you know what the ugly is right
the ugly is doing all the stuff that
people who lose aren't willing to do
you got to make those phone calls you
got to see people you're going to have
to put up with some rejection you got to
put yourself in an uncomfortable place
listen to me do it put yourself in an
uncomfortable place don't negotiate it
don't try to navigate it in your head
negotiation you will lose
okay unrealistic people rule the world
quit trying to be so daggum realistic
okay remember this weird rich normal
poor can you remember that say yes get a
little goofy
look at cardone he's a complete whack
job just so you know
and most people don't understand you can
obliterate most problems with just
massive action i see people hem and haw
and make excuses all the time when
challenges arise
and it would have just been solved if
you'd decided you'd have been totally
certain and you'd obliterate that
problem with some massive action
the people i know that are really happy
are very self-aware
in fact the best entrepreneurs i know
are very self-aware they're aware of
their shortcomings right they want to
improve them
they want to get to the next version of
themselves all the time and so
for me self-confidence comes because i
didn't have it and i think anytime you
meet somebody like yourself or
myself who might now appear
self-confident it's because i
really had to find tools and resources
because i was so insecure and shy
and introverted so i had to find
techniques and resources to build that
up in me
and for me it's very simple it's the
promises that i keep to myself
if i have a habit over and over
beginning to stack one on top of the
other of keeping promises i make to me
not other people
in other words the minute you begin to
get external in your life worrying about
what other people think about you right
you've you've lost all control you
and it never fills you up and people's
admiration people's
gratitude towards you will never fill
you up it's your own it's your own
inside
and so for me self-confidence comes from
keeping the promises i make to myself
and the other part of it is
being aware i'm doing it in other words
most people don't give themselves enough
credit all the time
they're very aware of these 20 things
and not aware of the 80
right and that's why the dosage is so
important too you've nailed it it
should be 80 20 right because people get
addicted to this
i'm not good at this people don't like
this about me i don't feel good instead
of focusing on the 80
and stacking up wow i did eat what i
said i was going to today i did get up
when i said i was going to i made the
amount of phone calls i treated people
in such a way i promised myself
it's not just doing those things it's
rewarding it's being aware of it and
stacking that up
well i love the house sometimes the
things that we think are the biggest
inconvenience end up being the best
blessings
absolutely man almost every single time
in fact i posted a speech today
that i gave i went i got invited back to
speak to uh my college alma mater's
baseball team i played college baseball
at university of pacific
and um i went back there and spoke to
the guys and there's a part in the talk
where i
tell them that i was so introverted my
senior year i wasn't going to graduate
and i had to take two electives so i was
going to graduate and i got
i had previously dropped out of a sign
language class
sign language because i had to get up in
front of the class and sign
it was i didn't have to even speak i
just wouldn't walk up there move my
fingers around and i dropped the class
and so
it put me where i wasn't going to
graduate and so the only class i could
take to graduate was drama
and public speaking and i had to take
them both and in the public speaking
class i found a giftedness of mine
right and so what you're saying is
completely true i talk about in this
speech
typically on the other side of your
greatest fear
of your greatest insecurity is your
greatest blessing everyone goes well get
out of your comfort zone you'll find
this no no
what you're afraid of and what you're
insecure about on the other side of that
is typically one of the great gifts or
blessings in your life
and so that's exactly right you and i
are talking right now
because i took a public speaking class
my senior year i was stone ass afraid of
in college that's why you and i are
talking right now so you're right
you're right you're right and how many
people have been touched now because of
you taking that class
and and mutual right and somehow that
blessing that
seemingly inconsequential scary pain in
the ass for me
changed my entire life and has changed
frankly millions of other people's lives
because i went around that thing i was
afraid of it's like you don't even know
the magnitude
of what it's costing you to give into
your fears and insecurities
and by the way insecurities and fears
are different things they're both
really insidious detrimental things that
people struggle with
and so on the other side of your fear
that's one thing and on the other side
of your greatest insecurity
are blessings and you have no idea the
immeasurable waves
that you're missing in your life because
you are giving in to them
and cowering to them and so it's like my
life's totally different
take me a little deeper there what
what's the difference between fear and
insecurity
well fear is something that as you stare
at it there's a
reaction in your body that's actually
healthy it's to protect you
we have fear in our nature because way
back in the day
this is how we survive right so fear is
not an unhealthy thing
what it is is it's an alert to you that
hey there's something here you need to
be more aware of
fear is an awareness emotion what most
people think is it's an avoidance
emotion
fear is to make you aware right so i had
a little
fear and an odd way when my daughter was
being born when my son was being more
i wasn't afraid of having a daughter it
was an awareness of all the great things
that could come with it and my
fear of what could go wrong that day
right so thank god my daughter was born
so that fear wasn't
some sign it shouldn't happen or we
shouldn't go through with it
it was a hyper awareness insecurity is a
lie you tell yourself
insecurity is completely different
insecurity
is mainly things that don't exist that
you should not be aware of
so ironically people conflate these two
things and insecurity
is something that you've told yourself
that is more than likely a lie about you
i'm stupid i'm short nobody loves me no
one's
going to listen to me i'm not strong
enough i'm going to blow this right
what are they going to think about me
these are all fabrications of your
imagination
fear is a real thing that you should
acknowledge and see and respond to
favorably
insecurities are lies and so
most people don't make that distinction
and they actually
think their insecurities are things they
should be aware of
when in fact insecurities are things you
should not be aware of
totally different thing you wanted to be
a professional baseball player yeah
right
yep but then you got an injury i did
similar to me so you never made it to
the big leagues or did you play minor
league for a little bit i did yeah and i
played division 1 college baseball too
yeah i
like every guy like you and i talked
about this last time it's always our
injuries that ended our careers i
probably it probably put me
into a premature place where i was going
anyways i don't really realize you
weren't gonna be in the base for
i wasn't i played enough baseball with
guys who ended up in the big leagues to
know my limitations yeah so
like anything in life things happen for
you not to you that injury happened for
me it certainly didn't seem like it at
the time
but it got me out of that and into
something like what we're talking about
now that completely changed my life so
yeah but yeah i want to be an athlete
for sure all my life
all your life that was my mask and then
when it exactly and then when
it ended your identity was like who am i
right
yes lost yeah like a lot you and i were
just telling this before we went on yeah
you know our professional athlete
friends were their career changes
i went into a like anybody like whatever
your dream is when the first one
ends it doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage
it ends it was a dream right or a
business venture or a sport
i went into a pretty good depression and
uh how old were you at the time
21 22. and i ended up
you know it's because people always see
the after like the house or whatever
houses or whatever the material things
are but i ended up
bad man i ended up depressed i ended up
moving back at home with my parents i
was living in the city
i remember i was living in this sleeping
of the same bed i grew up in with the
same teddy bear the same posters
i was like going back in time like six
years i'm back where i was
totally unemployed and uh couldn't find
work
didn't have the motivation to get up and
find a job just sort of eating out of
their fridge and laying around all day
so that's where i was many many years
ago after baseball you realize things in
your life happen for you truly
especially in hindsight everybody knows
it in hindsight right if you look back
at any disaster
tragedy most people look back five ten
years later they go that happened for me
that was actually a good thing
and so i was unemployed i couldn't find
a job and
my old man my dad was the best dad role
model you could ever have in your life
hard-working man
good man it's better man than me has
more integrity than me he's the best man
i've ever known
but when i was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober
recently and he was going to these
meetings
and he comes home from one of his
meetings and says there's a guy at my
meeting
who can get you a job it's right down
the street in san dimas
you're gonna be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning eight
am ask for tim
so i walked i drive down there it's a
place called mckinley home for boys
little did i know that would alter my
entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so i walk in there i said i'm at my
let i'm here for the job they're like
what job
i'm like i don't know just my dad told
me to show up here yeah
i need to ask for tim they're like we
have no idea who the hell tim is what's
his last name
i said i i don't i don't know his last
name and they're like so you showed up
for a job that you don't know what it is
and you don't know who it is that's
hiring you i'm like here's what i know
he's an alcoholic
like oh yeah we know that too and so
they bring me to the guy and he says uh
you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these
eight boys that were my boys they were
seven eight and nine years old
and basically i lived with these boys
these precious
boys and we ended up adding a few more
my boys were all wards of the court
they were all molested by family more
parents were in prison
and so they had no family and so my
whole life changed all of a sudden these
became i'm this 22 year old guy
these guys become my sons wow and i
did holidays with them i did birthdays
with them i lived with them
literally in a home or like a literally
mckinley is a massive
campus full of children that have been
displaced from their homes that live in
individual like cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really
yep all boys it's in san dimas here and
um
wow it just altered my life man because
i i'd been an athlete had a huge ego had
that mask i wanted to compete i wanted
to win i wanted attention i wanted
recognition
first time literally in my life i went
wow i
i love helping people i love making a
difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just i always say this all the time
and i have those eyes too you have them
i think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction
they just have different eyes yeah they
just have these eyes that are these boys
all were different but they had that
same eyes they're just like
man love me believe in you you know care
about me and i had those eyes because i
grew up in an alcoholic family
and my whole life changed i just went
wow i love
i actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives i didn't know
that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud
all of a sudden i was in a stud and all
of a sudden it wasn't about me it was
about these 10 boys that ended up being
10 of them
and it just altered my life man and so
after that i ran into the financial
business that i ended up in
but i would have completely flunked out
of that financial business had i not
been with my boys for those years and i
was there for two years
two years yeah man like eight hours a
day type of thing or sometimes more
sometimes 16 18. i
i think about i'm not kidding you i
think about my boys and my experience
there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where i
reflect on that it altered
me completely like what i wanted to do i
always wanted to be
famous and rich and successful and now i
just wanted to serve
yeah i wanted to help little did i find
out i could get rich
and famous and all that other stuff i
thought i wanted through serving
people i had a really good friend of
mine i went to lunch and he said
i don't know who this guy is here in
front of me and he goes let me ask you a
question honestly
right now what are you grateful for and
at the lunch i said
jack nothing brother there's nothing
good in my life right now
and i'm not exaggerating this to you
when i tell you this and this is a
factual story
as i'm mouthing these words two people
walked in with an older man both of them
clearly were fighting cancer somehow
both had lost their hair one of the
ladies had a bonnet on
and they were barely moving in both
walked by our table and gave me the most
warm greeting the warmest smile as a
stranger
and he goes that's pretty freaking
pathetic you can't find anything in your
life to be grateful for right now
and on the drive home i'm not kidding
you i started to stack gratitude
i started to take inventory because if
you can find things to be grateful for
in that space
man is your life going to be rich when
there really are external things to be
grateful for
so my first mechanism out of that space
was honestly
to stack the things i was grateful for
and i started reinforcing it
over and over and over again and what
happens is
there's this reticular activating system
in our brains right
and all of a sudden because that's the
messaging i was giving myself
all of a sudden all these things start
to come into my awareness that i'm
grateful for
i start to magnetize to myself some
people that i needed to find into my
life and that was the next layer
i started to see things to be grateful
for my health my fitness
people who loved me and what it is it
changed my state when i stacked
gratitude i changed what i did in the
morning
and i changed what i did in the evening
and so somehow by grabbing control of my
morning
and by grabbing control of my evening i
got some measure of control over the
middle of my day
i was an out of control person back in
those days meaning this i woke up
worried stressed fearful and i
immediately start thinking about a bill
i had to pay something that was wrong
and i'm in a state of reaction to begin
every i'm talking within
six minutes of waking up six seconds
most people listen to this that's what
they do
i said i gotta grab control of my
morning and i set up routines in my
morning
maybe they served me maybe they didn't
but they were things i could deliver on
doing for myself
and so not only did that give me control
over the day but i started to stack my
self-confidence too
i want to turn my mentors into my
friends like you know how you and i are
gonna we're gonna become great friends
because the highest level of influence
is actually friend like if you have kids
anybody out there the truth is the most
you guys are so young but
you don't really worry about who their
teachers are that's their mentor you're
about who they hang out with you know
this one when you were a kid right
friends so you got to turn your mentors
into friends long term but for me
when i was a little boy i played
baseball miracle i'm at a baseball camp
rod crews there who's a hall of fame
baseball player he's he's the guest
coach at the baseball camp all the other
kids
hey can i get an autograph blah blah
blah i went up to him and said mr crew
will you be my coach
i'm eight years old wow eight years old
will you be my coach i'm this little
left-handed hitter he's rod crew if you
don't know who he is google it right
and he goes i might coach you let me see
you hit and i get in the cage and i
batted just like him he used to bat with
his bat flat like this instead of up and
i batted just like him and
he ends up meeting my dad and he goes
you know i was thinking of starting a
hitting school why isn't he being my
first student
so when i'm eight years old my hitting
coach ends up becoming rod crew until i
leave to go to college
is that crazy and then once i got into
the business world though i knew that
principle
and so i would start to put myself an
environment so tony robbins has been a
major influence on me i had a goal my
goal was i went to one of his seminars
and i'm like okay well that was cool
but i want to know him and so over time
i sought them out sought them out sought
them out and then
you know the way you get a mentor
eventually too is that somehow there's
reciprocity involved you bring them some
value yeah
you teach them something you give them
something they can't get whether it's
love belief care
time admiration whatever it is so tony's
been a major one for me
uh phil knight's been a significant one
for me uh stallone's been one these are
you know the point of my life now where
those are guys that have made a major
major impact on me and what mentors do
for you is they not only teach you
things
but they they make you want to live up
to their belief in them
and i think the other thing is they can
hold you accountable differently than
you can yourself because
you don't want to let someone down whom
you respect the dad principle that you
said earlier right
so i haven't won in my life because i'm
trying to prove something to tony
robbins
but part of the steps of my life have
been when i make a verbal commitment to
him that i'm going to do something i
want to build a reputation with him that
i keep my promises
and that's different and so that's what
my mentors have done for me and i still
seek them out
all the time in whatever area that i'm
moving towards
i'm always trying to find out who's the
best at this who should i build a
relationship with who should i
collaborate with
there's this thing people think that
like i'll be happy when
once i get like this big amazing home or
once i get this
car or once i get this relationship or
an amount of money then i'll allow
myself some happiness the problem is
the finish line always moves you never
arrive there right
the other part is people think well if i
enjoy myself now
i'm going to lose my drive in other
words if i can just wire myself with
enough pain
all the time i won't lose my driver
ambition the truth is there's no
correlation between the two at all
there's no relationship between you
feeling complete pain all the time and
losing drive and so
i talk about living in a state of
blissful dissatisfaction and
really the best example of that would be
like if you've ever i love a good meal
right you know if i bite into a great
piece of steak if you're a steak eater
like i
am you take that first bite it's like
complete bliss right
there's no correlation between how great
that tasted and your lack of desire for
the next bite
in fact that bliss causes you to want
more of it
and so the more we can be to reward
ourselves with bliss we're not going to
lose our dissatisfaction we're not gonna
we're not gonna lose that and so
for me our brains this dopamine hit you
get
when you do something successful if you
constantly cheat yourself out of that
hit
right biomechanically in your body less
and less in the future where you want to
achieve
the next level the next dream the next
step and that's why so many people stall
out in life
they didn't they got to a certain point
and they cheated themselves out of the
bliss out of the celebration it's
important
that we celebrate our wins we celebrate
our lives because it causes us to want
the next bite
it keeps us hungrier not the reverse and
so for me i want to live in a state of
being grateful
and blissful now not waiting for some
future place or date that may never
arise biggest money mistake i made in my
life
is investing in things that i don't
understand and
um were too complicated like uh stocks
yeah stocks i bought that i knew nothing
about that i heard on uh at cnbc i
should buy
or having some guy uh the one thing i
like about your real estate deals it's
straightforward it's it's it's simple
it's easy to understand if you present
me a deal now and i can't regurgitate it
back to you real quick in some simple
form i'm not investing in it
i need to at least understand what it is
i'm investing in yeah even if even if
you miss something you're willing to
miss something
i'll miss something yeah i've missed so
many things yeah so if i can't
understand it or it's too complicated
and i can't repeat it back to you pretty
quickly you lost me yeah what was so
what's the biggest loss you had in in
in not following that advice um
i bought yahoo stock at about i don't
remember 75 or 80 bucks a share and i'm
talking like when i had about 3 million
bucks i put like 800 grand in there
and i think i ended up selling it at
like 17 how about city groups
would you buy that i think in the 70s or
80s i couldn't go to the exact garment
and then like after i learned that
lesson i thought 240 grand yeah then i
no no you lost
700 grand and then i'll give you two
more biggies second one i did is i
um i bought city bank stock city group
stock at like fifty four dollars a share
yeah 2008 which is like 700 000
worth of that and i think i sold it at
250 2.50
is when i finally sold it because i
heard they were going to be the next
aig yeah they're worth 200 and then the
third one is stuff you talk about
i bought a residential real estate
property
that did not provide any revenue did not
provide any equity for me
that was uh what would you call it it
would be like a
a trophy property like hey i'm a big
shot right i'm in the big time
i bought one of those that wasn't that
long ago either and that was a
property that i wasn't going to use
wasn't getting leverage out of didn't
generate revenue i didn't know anything
about the market i was buying and i just
wanted to look like a big shot and i
think i lost two and a half million on
that house
and that wasn't that long ago that's
just a few years ago so i've still made
some mistakes in my life
but those are probably the biggest loss
probably that house on one deal was
probably that house i lost two and a
half years
three million maybe i lost three million
on that what does max out
really stand for for you and when did
that moment happen where you knew that
that was gonna be part of your brand
yeah um
my son's name's max so that helped um
but maxed out to me means this as you
know
um your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll
eventually possess so if you're obsessed
with what you're worried about your
fears your problems you're going to
possess those
and so i became obsessed um
the the short version is is that you
don't know this i don't talk about this
on camera very much
when i was 30 my uncle died at 50 years
old
and he was the guy in my family we all
have this that you kind of resemble
or remind everybody else my dad's
brother he died at 50.
sorry no thank you i appreciate that
it's a long time ago now
and um but he was kind of with my
godfather and on my culture that's a big
deal
of course might as well yeah i know
shout out uncle mike yeah mine was uncle
mike
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's got chills
everywhere right there
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa that's how the universe works right
wow okay you got me right there
so mine was my uncle mike
wow and no man i just touched me
so mine was my uncle mike and uh
that blows my mind right there brother
so
i'm on i'm at his funeral we're flying
back
on the flight there's this thing in your
brain called the reticular activating
system it basically filters into your
awareness what's important to you
that's why like if you buy a new car all
of a sudden you see that car everywhere
on the freeway three lanes over on the
other side boom another one
they were always there why do you see
them now it's filtered into your
importance
and heart attacks where he died of a
heart attack and so i'm on the airplane
and i'm listening to music and on the
screens the oprah show but i'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart on
the screen i'm like
unplug my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at cedar
signing where they could like it's
common now but they could not evasively
look at your heart and your arteries
long story short i hear it and i told my
wife i said schedule me for one of those
exams
she's like it's expensive i don't care
schedule it we call it's a nine month
wait i go i need to get in i need to get
in i keep calling the lady finally she
goes there's a cancellation tomorrow at
two i go i'll be there
so i go down for the scan and thank god
this doctor understood influence and
leverage do you do the scan
then you come back after lunch i
literally went ate a burrito
came back i wasn't in shape i'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
i'm no i'm looking for edward mylett i
go it's my let you know and he goes uh
he knew
he goes whoa i can't believe these
arteries are in that young body
wow you need to come back son now my
heart's racing i'm like what the hell's
in the skin we sit down instead of what
a normal doctor would do they just go
hey um
here's the prescription take crest store
workout eat goodbye
he understood reasons is what changes
people's lives
massive reasons not discipline reasons
and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful um
do you have kids i go yeah i go i got a
son he's one he goes that's great um do
you want to be there when he graduates
high school
i went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school i
said uh yeah he goes
okay uh is she pregnant huh i go yeah
what does she have and i said a girl
you get to a dad this is what you say he
goes would you like to walk that little
girl down the aisle on her wedding day
son i went what what is in this scan
dude and he goes i want to be very clear
with you young man i remember this like
yesterday because i want to be very
clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man is going gonna live
with your beautiful wife
in your mansion walk your son at
graduation and he's gonna be arm in arm
with your daughter on her wedding day
not you you'll be a long god
actually as i tell you this right now
dude right and he goes
what i'm gonna get you to do is i'm
gonna get you to max out your life
and your fitness and i went
give me it yeah and he gave me exactly
what i needed to do and he said if you
do this you'll walk her down the aisle
blah blah blah from that day
when i get up like i did this morning
and i'm tired and i was late last night
and i don't want to go to the gym
i swear to you brother i swear to you i
go bella's wedding
get your ass up and i go i i'm fit
because i have massive
reasons that's why i'm fit and that
started the journey towards maxing out
every area of my life i'm like if i can
do this in my fitness i can do this in
business i can do this in my
spirituality
and everything i'm not going to
shortchange myself by pretty good i'm
going to see what my real potential is
what my maximum capacity is every single
day
because at the end of my life when i do
die i have this belief that when i'm
done the lord's gonna go well done
good and faithful servant and by the way
here's the man you could have been
this is the man you were born to be this
is the man you were destined to be this
is where you could have gone but you
could have seen the memories you could
have had the people you could help the
person you could have become
and meet him my obsession is that every
day i'm chasing that dude so that when i
do die we meet we're identical twins
because the bad end of a life whether it
would be at 30
50 or 150 would be i meet that guy and
we're total strangers yeah so i'm
obsessed with meeting that guy someday
and that's what maxing out means the key
to self-confidence is really simple and
this is absolutely i've trained hundreds
of thousands of people i've spoken to
millions of people around the world i
can tell you this the self-confident
people i know whether they are athletes
school teachers mechanics
parents stay-at-home moms you name it
they have a pattern of keeping promises
they make to themselves
the groundwork of beginning to build
self-confidence
is to begin to keep the promises you
make to you and that's why it's
important to begin to even make small
problems if you're going to get up at a
certain time in the morning
not only do it but then give yourself
credit say i did what i said i was going
to do if it's in your diet or your
fitness
don't just eat the healthy foods go i'm
doing what i said i was going to do
you begin to build this reputation if
you're constantly being influenced and
moved by what other people think about
you it means there's a deficiency in
what you think about you
and so the key is not some you know and
so
esoteric like belief system it's a
pattern of keeping the promises that you
make to you
that's the groundwork of self-confidence
for sure
and it is a pattern when i meet people
that lack confidence i think let me
serve you let's begin to keep the
promises you make to you you're so
worried about there's this addiction to
other people's approval in the world
right it's the greatest
the greatest addiction today it used to
be drugs before there was alcohol
there's all these addictions sex
addictions whatever
the number one addiction in the world
today is the addiction to other people's
approval
and that's because we don't approve of
ourselves we or we don't feel a spirit a
universe a god that we believe in that
approves of us and so
my confidence comes from both my faith
and in the fact that i keep promises i
make to myself that's the groundwork of
all confidence
see at the end of my life the lord's
gonna go hey by the way this guy over
here
this is the man you could have been this
is the person you were born to be
this would have been your dreams this is
where you would have gone what you would
have seen who you would have helped what
you would have changed this would have
been your book
meet him my dream in my life is that
when i meet that person we're not total
strangers
you don't want to get to the end of your
life and that character is a total
stranger to you you know damn well
there's going to be a funeral for you
someday
at that funeral there's gonna be a sense
in the spirit of what you could have
become
the woman the man you could have become
and every day those decisions you're
making to max out your life
are chasing that person see you know
what i want at the end of my life when i
meet him i want to be identical twins
ted and ed are gonna meet each other
someday and i'm gonna say hey man
good to see you been chasing you man
he's gonna go i've been watching you
you're exactly like me man we're
identical twins you
maxed out your damn life congratulations
i believe everything has a vibration
because everything has an energy right
and so that i have without getting too
complicated
i have to quiet myself because when i
get quiet i
vibrate at a higher frequency and so
that i can tap into
see the same thought the same energy
that made this ocean that made the world
that made you and i
i have access to that limitless
absolutely perfect thinking in mind and
so
the only way that i get that is by
getting out of my own way getting out of
my own space getting out of my own junk
and so i access it for me by getting
quiet the key to my life is that
in the morning and i do it in the
morning it's nice now that i can do it
with the ocean here i also live on a
lake
is i just it doesn't take a long time i
just take 20 minutes and i access it and
i get quiet and the only way i can
access it is to get out of my head and
so i quiet and empty my mind
and i access the universe that's what i
do your mind gravitates towards which it
is most familiar with
and so if you're really familiar with
what you're worried about and what your
problems are and your fears are and that
becomes your dominating thinking i know
you've all heard this but here's the
reason why your mind
loves what's familiar okay and so if you
don't go touch dreams for example
just experience it for a second for
example we would go down
once every eight weeks if i did well in
business we really knocked it out we
could find a deal i had 200 bucks we'd
go to the ritz carlton or some hotel
ocean and for one day oceanfront feel
like what it felt like to
valet your car right walk in the lobby
mr milette welcome back
right she'd go get a massage i'd play a
little bit of golf
and just for that day i'd touch the
dream and then maybe we do it again in a
month or two and again in a month just
little taste of it my mind began to
begin to become familiar with it and
more crazy i started to kind of trick
myself into thinking i belonged there
because we never end up anywhere we
don't believe we don't belong and that
we're not familiar with so there's these
things you'd like to do in your life
either visually seeing them over and
over again or repeating those images to
yourself that's powerful
but a double whammy is to not only
repeat them and see them but to go to
see there's one thing that's a visual
stimulus in your brain that makes you
want to do something
the triple whammies if you could see it
touch it feel it and smell it
if you allow all your senses to
experience something it becomes far more
familiar to your brain
and so i'm a massive massive advocate of
touching a dream in any form you can get
it the best of which is actually going
and experiencing it
short term begin to believe you belong
there you're a little bit better
and so i you will not probably produce
many things in your life that you've not
visited either
mentally or literally thousands of times
and so
if you want to end up somewhere you
better be visiting them those could be
dreams visions
but the most important thing is if you
could actually more powerful so you go
touch them short term
massive difference drive by the
neighborhood see the cars if you want to
spend your life in service for your
church or your community
take a day out every month and actually
do it know what it feels like for an
afternoon to feed the homeless or to do
and you begin to love it and feel it and
believe you belong there
more and more chance that you'll be able
to do that full time someday one thing i
want to challenge you to be as a leader
of your business
whether it's just you're a leader of one
which is you as a salesperson
or a leader of 10 as a team or a company
of 25 000 employees is
you must become evangelical about your
cause and your mission
the greatest business people have an
evangelical property about them they're
evangelizing
all the time they're propagating the the
strengths the benefits of their business
of their mission of their cause
one of the great evangelists of all time
is steve jobs is a great book
written by a guy named guy kawasaki many
years ago called selling the dream
and in that book he talks about the way
that steve jobs sold the dream of apple
and he literally called him an
evangelist for the cause
there's a great story in that book about
steve jobs when he was recruiting
he knew he needed to have a ceo of his
company and he wanted to have the best
and at that time there was a man named
scully who was the head of pepsi and
jobs was this young kid in his twenties
trying to recruit this executive who
made millions of dollars and
he couldn't get him and he couldn't get
him and he couldn't get him and finally
he gets the voicemail back in those days
the answering machine actually of scully
and he says listen
listen man when you're tired of selling
sugar water to kids over there at pepsi
and you want to come change the world
freaking call me back and we'll do it
together
boom and he hangs up right he was
evangelical the cause
sugar water and pepsi changed the world
at apple right and scully who's making
millions of dollars a ceo of one of the
most powerful companies in the world
looks to his wife and she says i think
he's right
we aren't changing the world and it was
that one cause-oriented evangelical
phone call from steve jobs and it exuded
out of his pores
every stage speech he gave every
one-on-one every board meeting
when he'd meet with their software
engineers when he'd meet with the
programmers
he was always evangelical internally and
externally and built a culture of one of
the greatest
movements of all time in the history of
business investment of belief in people
sowing seeds of belief
that's what makes you a leader people
say what makes me a leader makes you a
leader is your example
what makes you a leader is you investing
belief and loving and caring about
people any one of you
in this moment could decide you're going
to lead because leadership is instilling
something in someone that they don't see
in themselves
loving on them believe in them seeing
their gifting is all of you i don't care
if you're
loud or quiet big here or small here you
could be a leader
the bottom line is you need to decide
you want to lead
influence is energy it's the transfer of
energy it's getting you to
feel about my company feel about my
mission feel about my product
feel about my cause what i feel they're
conscious of
transferring energy to people because
that's what moves people that's what
gets them to act
it's not just the words it's not just
your face it's not just how you're
dressed
it's an energy transfer there's a hook
by the way
you can't transfer to me that which
you're not experiencing yourself
you have to physically be experiencing
it in the moment it can't just be the
words you're reading from a sheet
you have to really believe it one of the
reasons a lot of sales people struggle
or recruiters struggle is they just
don't believe enough they don't spend
enough time
making the case like a lawyer litigating
to themselves
about how powerful what they do is and
the more and more you really if you're a
true believer you can evangelize your
product you can evangelize your message
so invest more time in your own belief
in your research
in your knowledge finding third-party
articles magazines blogs things that
reinforce
whatever it is you're doing that feeds
your own belief
that way you can give it to me you can't
give it to me if you don't have it
so how many of you believe in your life
that your worst day can become your best
day
if you turn it around i happen to
believe that that honestly the old
in a lot of books you read oh there's a
seed of every adversity there's a seed
of greatness you've all heard that
before right but it's actually true
if you were to go back in your life some
of the greatest trials and tribulations
difficulties you've gone through
have end up producing the most beautiful
things in your life is that true yes
let me tell you one thing i've noticed
about all the max out performers that
i've interviewed on my program that i've
known throughout my life for the last
30 years really in business sports
entertainment
politics you name it the elite
performers look at time
and use time completely differently than
the people who perform at an average
level so let's start out the first thing
i want to tell you
about people who win who max out
they are in a much bigger hurry than the
people who are average and i'm not
kidding you when i say this they're in a
bigger hurry to get to their destination
to get to their outcome their pace is
faster they walk faster they talk faster
and their expectation when they're going
to arrive at their destination is sooner
this may seem like a very small subtle
thing but i want you to evaluate
how big of a hurry are you in because
there's something to be said about how
close you think you are to a goal
and how fast you will run to get to the
finish line let me give an example of
that
if you and i started out right now we
had a 26 mile marathon to run
right in our minds it was 26 miles we
were going to race each other
we would pace ourselves at a certain
speed
in order to maintain that speed because
of the duration of the run
so it was a marathon we'd jog wouldn't
we pretty slowly you certainly wouldn't
sprint 26 miles and so because the
destination
because the finish line is so far away
our pace or our hurry is limited based
on
how far away we think we are or when
we'll arrive there but if you and i were
to run a 100 yard dash
would the pace be the same because the
finish line is so much closer
we'd run full speed from the minute we
took off wouldn't we because of the
proximity
of how close the finish line is the
people that win
in life don't necessarily have more
vision than you
see it's not a lack of vision always
that means that you're going to lose
it's a lack of a type of vision which is
depth perception
you think you're further away from the
outcome and so you pace yourself like
it and you jog all the time throughout
your life
the people that win may have a bigger
vision but they have accurate
depth perception they understand how
close their goals are how close their
outcome is
and they're constantly in a sprint to
get there throughout their day
that means consequently they get started
earlier and they finish later
they get up earlier throughout the day
they're in a bigger hurry to get to the
places they need to be because the
finish line in their mind is so much
closer
i cannot emphasize this enough to you is
just the pace
and the way time shrinks for elite
performers compared to the average
i'm telling you the average performer
can say the same things read the same
books
have the same schedule yet the person
who is in a bigger hurry throughout the
day ends up winning the day
winning the week winning the month
winning the year and winning the light
so you are one of the greatest not just
influencers but
and speakers publicly thank you that are
in the world right now for those that
you know are looking to step up and
become a brand right now they
they have that desire they want to
become speakers you know what
how do you master that craft of being
able to
get into a flow and really connect with
your audience
watch the people that are out there how
do they deliver their message where do
they hold their hands i'm not saying you
should copy people i'm saying study it
study their i i studied because it was
pre-social media
i studied preachers on tv to this day i
watched stand-up comedians
constantly i'm addicted to it because
they're funny and i watch how they roll
out a line i watch how they deliver a
message i watch do they walk when they
talk
do they stop when they're making the
important point how do they use their
hands do they raise their voice do they
lower their voice how comfortable are
they with silence
so i watch people who can communicate
all the time the separation is always in
the preparation
so my confidence always comes from how
prepared i am when i speak i told you
earlier i need to prepare for tomorrow
i know what i'm going to say but i've
got to really prepare my confidence the
separation for me
comes into preparation left to my own
devices
right if you just left me like what i'd
like to do hey man
i have no problem laying around um i
like sleeping i got people think
they meet people like you know they're
like they're robots their other life
forms they're just different than me
no we build habits rituals and
disciplines that serve us
okay now part of those habits rituals
and disciplines have sort of turned me
into a more confident person there's no
question about that
so my standards are mandatory because
you get your standards right so
the reason my standards are set so high
is because i don't want to leave it up
to my own devices
right my standard is one more minute on
the treadmill my standard is
one more person i can reach that day one
more phone call one more something
and so for me i raise them every single
year but the way i get to do it as i
link it to my reasons
and so goals are really empty to me i
have a thing on goal setting but like my
big thing is that
you show me something with compelling
emotional gigantic reasons i'll show you
someone who's changing their standards
all day long so like
give you one quick version that you've
not heard before one of the reasons i'm
relatively fit
is not just peak state
i have an uncle in my family that died
at 50 years old of a heart attack my
godfather my dad's only brother i kind
of
resembled him and i look like him a lot
so
on the way back from his funeral my
reticular activators on heart attacks
on the tv screen on the airplane i'm
listening to music is the oprah winfrey
show she's going through a new heart
scan
unplugged my headphones plugged into the
airplane one there's some of this new
scan at cedar sinai that at that time
was new it could read the plaques and
your arteries the calcifications without
going
you know really invasively i scheduled
it i went in
i had a world-class doctor who
understood reasons and leverage instead
of just prescribing
what when we coaching you need to do
this you need to do this doctors do it
take this pill take this
he understood leverage and reasons what
you do is you take the scan then you go
to lunch you come back
i took the scan i went to i had a
burrito i came back and i'm in the la
when i walk in i sit down the doctor
comes up and he says
oh my i can't believe these arteries are
in that young body
got my attention we walk back in we sit
down he could still go you need crest
store
eat clean get out of here is that what
an average doctor does right no
wired me with huge reasons he goes let
me ask you a question
uh i heard your wife's pregnant you have
i said i have a son and he says do you
want to be there when he graduates from
high school
to be there for that day i said yes sir
yeah
he goes your wife's pregnant what do you
have and i said a daughter this is where
you get a dad he goes
she was six months pregnant he goes do
you um would you like to walk her down
the aisle on her wedding day are you
okay that it's some other man
i went what the [ __ ] is on this scan
right like and he goes i want to be very
clear with you if you keep going down
the road you're going there'll be some
other man with your son at graduation
high school
and a stranger's walking your daughter
down the aisle that's not even born yet
on her wedding day and i went boom and
he goes but if you do exactly what i
tell you to do
you'll be there and so to this day
brother there are mornings when i wake
up not every morning i don't want to go
to the gym i go
bella's wedding bella's wedding bella's
wedding
so my standards are high because of my
big old reasons
other dudes may miss the gym that day
because they're not going to miss their
daughter's wedding if they don't go but
i've convinced myself i get emotional
i've convinced myself i'll miss my
daughter's wedding so i will get my ass
out of bed at four o'clock in the
morning and i will get to that gym
because my
reasons are bigger so my standards are
higher so that's what i think
causes us to have great standards as
huge reasons look i feel like most
people in their lives
are being allowed to live small you're
allowed to live a small life everyone
around you would like you to live small
just do this you're good at that man
take it easy chill when's enough enough
like come on brother you know where we
all these messages you get is basically
saying hey man
live small yeah life's not a big deal
live small enjoy it chill smoke a little
weed do whatever you want to want right
like it's just this
get by thing in life and there's got to
be some people going no
no you're supposed to do something great
with your life you were put here for a
purpose
your way the way you were born the way
you were raised
your background your experiences your
giftedness
all prepared you in your way for right
now
and you're supposed to do something
great with your life you weren't born
here to be average and ordinary
and there's all this messaging that
you're average and ordinary and you're
averaging right because you belong there
and it's probably someone else's fault
you're averaging ordinary too and i'm
like no
it's your life you're in control it's no
one else's fault and you're supposed to
do something
magnificent that's the consciousness
aspect the last
thousand years on earth doing something
great has been reserved to this one
little group of people
one percent of the population they're
supposed to do something great
they're supposed to live their dreams
we're supposed to watch them cheer for
them wear their jersey
watch their award show comment on their
posts
clean their houses right feed them in
their restaurants
no the fact of the matter is you can do
those things
you can change your life and i'm sick
and tired of this
hero worship you live small cheer for
everybody else who lives big
no if you're a school teacher be the
best damn school teacher change the
world by those little lives you're
affecting
if you're on social media change the
world play big
you will never do it wrong if your
decision is to do the bigger thing than
the smaller thing
that's what i would tell you stop
playing small stop thinking small and
don't let anybody tell you you should be
small
see in your life you're going to get
what you tolerate
stop tolerating for these people who
have believed in you all your life and
inferior life for you
stop allowing god to bless you and give
you all this giftedness and opportunity
and settle and tolerate less
for those babies that are sitting here
with you your children and grandchildren
stop being willing to tolerate less for
them don't tolerate it anymore
yeah you got to give it your best but it
starts making a decision that this is
over
i don't tolerate this life anymore
pretty good is not good enough for my
family
pretty good's not good enough for my
grandmother pretty good is not good
enough for my grandpa
my parents my future children pretty
good ain't going to get it done for this
family
now i hope you hear them whispering to
you he's right you can do this
you're great you're special you were
born for a reason
i hope you can feel that life's going to
give you
ultimately what you'll fight for i've
been getting asked lately about
the struggles people are going through
with self-doubt
not believing in themselves negative
thoughts about themselves
and i believe the solution to self-doubt
is to build
something bigger than that doubt which
is to build our self-confidence
and one thing to know about the fact
that you doubt yourself is one i
struggle with it as well one of the
reasons i've had to go learn to build
all these tools
for myself is because in my life my
baseball career my
academic career my business career my
speaking career
i've been riddled with self-doubt that
creeps up all the time in our lives am i
enough
am i good enough you weren't born
doubting you weren't
born discouraged you weren't born
thinking negative things about yourself
those were thoughts that were placed in
you and given to you
by an external source at some time in
your life it could even be our parents
don't do that be quiet sit down be a
good boy be a good girl maybe it was
criticism you received as a
as a little one that you may not even
remember to this day the process of
building self-confidence
is actually very easy believe it or not
self-confidence is self-trust
self-confidence is building a reputation
with yourself
that you keep your word to you that you
keep the promises you make to you
when i meet somebody who has a ton of
self-confidence i don't look at that as
somebody with a big ego
there's a difference somebody with
self-confidence has a reputation with
themselves that i do the things i
say i'm going to do that's where
self-confidence comes from when i meet
someone who is not self-confident
i know this is someone who has
consistently made promises to themselves
they've not kept they've started a diet
and done it for a while but not kept it
they've made a commitment and goals to
go make a certain amount of money in
business
and they started down the road but then
they didn't deliver on it long term to
get up at a certain time in the morning
and then they don't do it and so they
have a process and a habit in their life
more often than not of not keeping the
promises they don't make to other people
they don't keep the promises they make
to themselves and so the cool thing is
self-confidence is an internal game you
do not need external accolades external
admiration
in order to build self-confidence you
don't need any of those external forces
it's all done internally
you control this and you control this by
beginning today
to keep the promises you make to
yourself and you have to stack the deck
in your favor stack the game so you win
it's not good enough just to keep the
promises you make to yourself you must
acknowledge it
when you do it to you to give yourself
credit to create confidence momentum
is what i call it so whether that's
setting the deck where you're going to
get up a little bit earlier
you're going to make a certain amount of
phone calls you misses a certain amount
of appointments you're going to eat a
certain amount of calories in your
fitness you're going to spend a certain
amount of time with your children
or your parents and you begin to do
these things you say you're going to do
you say
simple things like i'm going to lay out
my clothes
the night before i go to bed every night
before i go to sleep so when i wake up
that decision is made for me and believe
it or not the fact that you just do
something that
simple that you then deliver on begins
to build
confidence or you say i'm going to
stretch in the morning when i get up and
you do it
all of a sudden i'm not going to check
my phone for 30 minutes all these habits
i teach when you just begin to do the
things you tell yourself you're going to
do
you begin to build self-confidence which
is this reputation with yourself
so ask yourself a question right now
what is one thing right now
one promise i can make to myself that
i'm going to begin to keep
starting this minute and begin to do it
it could be
how often i'm going to pick up a book
and read it but you begin to stack
things you commit to do
and then you deliver on them and you
acknowledge them to yourself you're in
the process of building
self-confidence why is that so important
of all the athletes i coach when my
athletes are performing at their peak
level
they're at their highest self-confidence
level in fact i love when i watch some
of the athletes i coach get interviewed
and they kind of do this aw
shucks humble routine in their post game
interviews yeah you know just part of
the team you know i got a lot i could
have done a lot better today
but inside i know these people are
incredibly self-confident people
any of you athletes listening to this
you know this the great athletes you
know have incredible amounts of
self-confidence you have to believe in
you when it's a battle when you're a
hitter against a pitcher
or when you're a quarterback against a
defense or you're a defenseman in the
nhl against their best offensive player
or you're a golfer and you have to make
a nine foot putt to win a tournament
right you better have self-confidence in
fact the separator
more often than not at the highest level
in sports is
not there a better shooter or a better
putter or
throw the ball a little bit faster
because everybody throws hard in the
major leagues nowadays
it seems right that separates their
self-confidence
it's true in being a parent it's true in
being a business person
it's true in every area of our life the
separator at the top levels
is self-confidence i had to learn to
recruit and build the team i'm
literally a broke man financially if i
did not build a team of people
so i had to learn to motivate and
inspire and teach and all those things
and building a team
this house is built by that team my lake
house built by that team the jets all
those things are built by the team that
i built
and so i learned early on and
collaborating so then when i went into
the personal development space i knew i
had to collaborate
so i sought out the right people to
build my support team around me their
audiences
you know i do their show they do my show
posting etc just like what we're doing
right now
and so i believe everything in business
nowadays is team built there's a
misnomer that someone is self-made
right yeah there's all these people out
there that are working out of their
homes right now
you cannot name a single successful
human being in the history of mankind
who didn't build a team jesus christ
built a team
he built a team he had his apostles for
a reason that was his
frontline team and then they built the
team there's nobody
ever in life who has built anything
extraordinary with their life alone
ever period you must collaborate you
must build a team
even the greatest religions in the world
were all built by teams of people
so clearly you in your living room right
now need to seed out some help some
teammates and some collaboration
do you ever think about what you think
about because if you did and if you took
control of that you could alter the
direction of your entire life
most people never take the time to take
an inventory
about their thoughts yet our thoughts
control our world our
thoughts are like magnets they literally
draw towards us
that's what we obsess about and so most
people never take the time to analyze
what they think about
the most successful people i know are
the most self-aware
meaning they're aware of what they do
and they're also aware of what they
think they're aware of how they're
perceived
average person you and i have about 75
000 thoughts a day rattling around in
this thing we call our brains
in our minds 75 000 of them the crazy
thing is
91 percent of those thoughts are
identical to the previous day
and identical to the day before that and
the day before that and the day before
that
and then we wonder why our life seems to
repeat itself over and over again so
really the difference in our life if we
have 75 000 thoughts a day here's the
crazy thing 91
of them are exactly the same the
separation in our life is in those nine
percent of their thoughts because
remember this
these magnets are pretty powerful that's
why i'm always saying that your
obsessions become your possessions
because they do
you draw into your life exactly what it
is you think about
it's a physical reality that you attract
to yourself what you think about
so the difference in our life is nine
percent of our thoughts that's why
people say all the time the difference
between winning and losing is so small
it's almost too scary to talk about and
really we've identified what it is it's
nine percent of what we think about
alters the direction of our life
so what i'm here to tell you today is
you've got to hone in and get aware of
what you think about
and then alter those nine percent of the
thoughts that are variable on a daily
basis
to serve you i was at the gym yesterday
and a woman drove by me in a wheelchair
at the gym
i was working out pretty hard and she
wheeled by me heavyset lady in a
wheelchair
i'd be honest with you i watched her
wheel past me
she inspired me do you know what courage
it takes to get in your wheelchair and
decide i'm going to go to the gym
right i'm going to go to the gym she's
heavy set awkward
that inspired me far more than the
jacked up dude doing 60 pound curls i
mean that's inspiring but you see that
a woman in a wheelchair at a gym with
her two pound dumbbells because her legs
don't work
but she went in there anyway and you
know how unsecure she was about going in
there she's the only person in a
wheelchair she doesn't know what she's
going to see
how people are going to react to her
she's not in shape she's never full
makeup on and her little
you know halter top like the other girls
in there and she's right in there
she was right in there working out right
next to them right i couldn't take my
eyes off her
i couldn't take my eyes off her and i
ended up telling her
that she was leaving i left what i was
doing i walked over i said i just want
you to know something
you're inspiring me this is wonderful
her face just lit
up because you know how sad she how
insecure she was about being in there
most inspiring person is the one
overcoming the fear of doing something
not the person who's excellent at it
i had some heart cardiac issues so
that's when i started to think about my
legacy
i don't need to be remembered that's for
some reason not been an important thing
to me that somehow like when i'm gone
that stuff's pretty overrated to me so i
do have two legacies the one is my
family
and what i want to be able to do for my
children and i want them to live a
better life than i've lived and i want
us to make a difference in the world
it occurred to me the last five or ten
years though that like i was put on
earth for a reason
there's a purpose to my existence
there's been a purpose to my journey
there's a purpose to my my in my heart
really wanting to help people like i i
love it
there's i ended up at a group home
working in the beginning of my business
career and it changed my life i was
working with these boys they were all
orphans and
very young i went oh that's my calling i
want to help
and now god's given me this platform and
the ability to put words together pretty
well right and so
i want to know that my life was better
for the world i feel like the world
today is
so divided i honestly believe that
real people from the grassroots i really
believe entrepreneurs
social media influence peoples who have
a voice in the world today
we can shift the consciousness of the
world i really believe that like and so
it's come to this point where like the
first half of my life was about building
something special for my own family
our own legacy and i've done that the
second half of my life is i want to help
contribute my part to changing the world
i want my great grandchildren to live in
a safer more collaborative more
loving world not just country i'm so
passionate about this bro
i sleep very little lately like i found
my calling
i found it and our voices all combined
those of you listening
you and i are louder than any one
politician or louder than any one
country
or louder than any one little segmented
you know little
group of people who are trying to get
their way in the world we can change
consciousness we are the voice
how bad do you want your goal right now
i think there's a lot of people in the
world today because it's a really niche
thing to talk about
i want this this is my outcome this is
my goal like how bad do you what do you
want as bad as breathing
do you want it as bad as anything you've
ever wanted in your life and if you
calibrate it
at the highest enough levels what i
found is the people that are the
hungriest
they find a way when you know why you
want something when it's
desperation the power of being desperate
is something that most people avoid they
think desperation is a weakness
and i'm here to tell you desperation is
one of the most powerful emotions
you could possibly possess because when
you're desperate you find
reserves and reservoirs of ideas talents
and a strength that you don't know you
have when you find yourself in a
desperate situation so ironically the
one thing most people avoid in their
life
hunger which is caused by being
desperate when you're starving
you become desperate think of somebody
who's starving on the street
they've got to how resourceful would you
get if your children were literally
starving and you had to feed them right
so the number one thing we need more
than anything to win
is hunger which comes from a state of
desperation
yet we're constantly trying to comfort
ourselves in the real world to avoid the
state of being desperate
and i'm telling you that i think you
need to embrace desperation again
in your life see in a fight you show me
two people
this is why it's so hard to repeat as a
champion in the fighting game
because you show me someone who's up and
coming who's hungry for that title who's
never had it before
who can taste it who knows if they win
that belt their whole life's going to
change they're going to be champion of
the world
all the endorsements all the money all
their family life
all their parents lives are going to
change you show me somebody
chasing that hungry for it against
someone who's just trying to hold on to
a title
and that's why most of the time the
challenger beats the champ it's hard to
repeat
as a champion because the hunger goes
down just a little bit
the greatest athletes the kobes the
bradys the jordans of sports
have a way of feeding their hunger all
the time and increasing it
what separates them isn't just their
work ethic isn't just their talent
although those things matter
isn't just they practice more what
separates them is they're just
hungrier they somehow find a way as they
climb up the ranks and win
championship to get even hungrier for
more where
99 of the athletes lose just a little
bit of their edge once they get that
first championship
that first pro contract that first big
amount of money that first world
championship they just lose their hunger
a little bit
and then there's the elite they get
hungrier it feeds the beast
no one's gonna do anything for you a
couple rules of being a real leader you
need to take responsibility
for your own life bring an energy to
your team leading and recruiting leading
in leadership
leading in growth nobody owes you
anything but you owe other people
everything that's what a leader does you
take responsibility you know exactly
right now what you're not doing
it would be criminal of you to leave
here and say i don't know what to do
you know exactly what you're afraid of
you know exactly what you've been
avoiding
and you've got to make a decision to
change it you know exactly what it is
don't bs anybody
you know what you need to do different
you know the changes you need to make
and if you can do that you stop kidding
yourself you can win you can overcome
your fear overcome procrastination
whatever that is you are not your
possessions you are not your
accomplishments you are not what other
people say you are you are not what you
look like
and guess what else you're not you are
not your patterns
but your life becomes a combination and
a result of your patterns
the great thing about us is that we can
change these patterns if we identify
them
the pattern has no power over you
once you know it's a program and a
pattern running the minute you start you
go my
i'm doing it again aren't i i'm doing
this thing i do every time i accumulate
money
i'm doing the same thing every time me
and my spouse get in a disagreement
i'm doing the same thing every time i'm
starting to feel loved by somebody
and i push them away every time things
start to go bad financially i spiral
every time there's adversity i do the
same pattern where i start worrying
every time i get fit i do the same
pattern
when you begin to see these things you
begin to go my gosh
this isn't who i am that's not your
identity there's a difference between
your
identity and your pattern and the more
you begin to build your identity as i've
talked about my other audios and be
aware of patterns
and then simply ask yourself when this
comes up again in the future
what pattern would serve me what pattern
can i take control of
what would be the steps i need to take
that will create the bliss i want
or the when i want or the production i
want what would the pattern need to be
you've got to start to build a habit of
being decisive successful
people happy people leaders are decisive
people
and i believe somewhere if there's a
hundred problems challenges in life
85 of them should be decided immediately
with not a lot of deliberation
and then certainty and massive action
will eliminate that challenge and that
problem most of the time
it's the people who procrastinate on the
problem or ignore it or think it might
go away
that gives that problem time to magnify
to fester to grow to where now it's
become bigger than it needed to be
probably the most important thing to me
in my life is i think that my children
think that their daddy helps people
and what they've learned from me both of
them is massive work ethic
both my kids are super hard-working good
people all i want them to
have when they leave my house is i want
them to have my work ethic
yeah i want them to have their faith and
i want them to have self-confidence
and i want them to be able to
communicate i think if you can leave
the family with those things work ethic
faith
self-confidence and the ability to
communicate you're probably going to
have a pretty good life
it takes care of every area your faith
is going to make sure you're a good
person and you contribute and you do
well and you've got morals
your self-confidence is obvious work
ethic is obvious
but the underestimated thing in life is
the ability to communicate your thoughts
and your ideas in the world today
information is a dime a dozen if you're
going to succeed in this life you have
to be able to communicate how you're
feeling and thinking
and transfer information to people and i
want them to be good at that too those
are the things i always think of with my
kids
problems need energy to live i want you
to own that remember this
problems need energy to live and so the
concept should be that we solve
problems but we don't have to pour and
deplete ourselves of energy
because the more energy you give
something the more it expands
we want to be in the max out universe we
want to pour our energy and expense our
energy
towards the solution not towards the
problem
so the first thing i want you to write
down is 90
of your energy focus time and thought
should be towards the solution
not towards the problem itself this is a
mistake most people make because they
expend all the energy into the problem
they obsess over the problem the problem
and when you expand energy it grows to
survive
and the problem gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger
and the solution becomes more and more
difficult so the first thing is can you
consciously begin to focus on
energy expansion into the solution 90
of it into the solution and not into the
problem what we do is we repeat that
problem
over and over and over again and we
magnify it
to the point where we don't come up with
realistic solutions and we deplete
ourselves as energy towards the solution
and so focus going forward when a
problem arises a challenge arises
that you focus 90 of your energy and
thoughts on the solution and not
repeating the problem to yourself
assuming you want more bliss in your
life decide to have it
and take some actions towards getting it
so let me ask you a question
what are you doing currently to create
more bliss
in your life what are the actions you're
taking to give yourself more bliss
you're intentionally seeking more bliss
because bliss is going to lead to more
wealth
more abundance more fitness more faith
better relationships
more happiness more peace more wins more
success more recognition more
significance
so what are you consciously doing now
that you've chosen bliss
what is the consistent action you're
taking to create more in your life
what are you doing to give yourself
bliss see great leaders
always sell the dream leaders must have
vision because of your position just by
being a position
of a leader you are in front of
everybody aren't you which means your
point of view should be different
you can see things they can't see your
job as a leader is to say here's what i
see
this is how amazing it is and this is
how we're going to get there so
great leaders like that book said sell
the dream
constantly great entrepreneurs are
constantly conscious of selling the
dream
to their employees to their clients to
their vendors
to potential clients to people they sell
to people they do business with to
people in the warehouse no matter what
your business is
i don't care what it is always be
selling the dream listen to me
always be selling the dream and do it
repetitiously
don't get tired of saying the same
things over and over again
see business is not about saying new
things to old people
business is about saying old things to
new people so
constantly be selling the dream people
quitting chargebacks
taking the exam that's all going to
happen just get ready
if you're an entrepreneur and you want
to do something great you're going to
have false start after false start
false start after false start get it
going then you don't get it going then
you don't your group grows then it
shrinks i'm telling you right now
just know that you're gonna make some
money then you're not being an
entrepreneur
tons of false starts tons of setbacks
but
see a guy like me i knew someone was
better than me
there's more talented people than me
probably more talented than you
but like my dad said the best of ability
is availability
you might outwork me for 30 days or 60
days or 90 days
but you ain't going to beat me over a
year you can't outwork me over two years
you are going to outwork me over three
years i'm gonna get you eventually i'm a
dripping damn faucet i just
keep coming at you just like you could
be right
just like you could i just keep coming
you might think i'm knocked out i just
keep coming
i'm too damn tough to give up most
people half-assed half their life all
the time
i knew they were going to get tired they
were going to flinch they were going to
get down
they may not quit they might send a
letter they quit getting wide they quit
recruiting people they quit improving
themselves
they start sleeping in they spend all
their damn money i'm not gonna do that
stuff i'm gonna save money i'm gonna get
up early i'm gonna keep getting wide i'm
gonna stay relentless
just like you should don't give in to
that stuff don't give in to the fears
don't give in to the setbacks
you're gonna have failure it's part of
the game one of the things that human
beings underestimate
dramatically is their capacity to get
great at something if they're totally
immersed in it
totally laser focused on something but
as i've coached the very high-end
athletes in my life the top business
people and entertainers
i can tell you that most people
underestimate what
total obsessive laser-focused really is
and what it looks like because you are
way
more powerful than you know you are if
you went crazy psycho obsessed laser
focused on anything
even something you're totally ill
prepared for humans have an unreal
capacity
to get great at things even if they
don't have a natural talent for it
if they're immersed in it and to learn
something and acquire a ton of knowledge
in a short period of time as well
society is conspiring
all the time in our culture to
completely distract you so you never win
to just divert your focus and attention
look over here look at this shiny thing
look at this tv show look at this sports
team worry about what's going on here in
this war
and they get these different things on
television and our phones
and in our lives that just get us
distracted so we never get obsessed we
never get laser focused
for an extended period of time you get
to choose your life you get to choose
how you feel not other people there's
these illusions in life
we really can't control anything other
than our own thoughts
our own behavior our own patterns we
can't control what other people do
say or think and it's this illusion of
control
often times that we can somehow
manipulate other people or manipulate
situations
that cause us to fall into these
patterns but we do have the power of in
life is we have the power to choose
and i say this to you because i'm
somebody just like you
i struggle with the different patterns i
have some of them serve me some of them
don't
i sometimes engage in thoughts that
don't create the right emotions for me
that don't serve me
i know what it's like to be frustrated
and angry and depressed and
down and lost and fearful and worried
worries a big one for me i love to fall
into the pattern of worry when certain
circumstances begin to happen
it creates a trigger and a pattern in me
and man do i
love to worry and so i give you these
tools and resources because these are
things i
too struggle with i've been able to
overcome them by just being aware
and choosing and so the first thing is
the power of choice
finish this sentence for me i choose to
be
blissful rather than blank
i choose to be blissful rather than
blank
what would your answer be one of the
emotions i challenge you to experience
more of in life
is bliss you know we are the calibration
of maybe the five emotions we experience
on a regular basis
and so if you're experiencing depression
frustration worry fear
anxiety pain on a regular basis you're
gonna have one life
if you're experiencing bliss and
fulfillment and ecstasy and joy
in in your life and contribution
recognition and significance if you're
experiencing love you experience those
emotions
you have a totally different life we
have the power to choose which emotions
we want to experience
whatever it is good bad or indifferent
in your life
your current level of happiness of joy
of success of fulfillment is exactly
what you think you deserve
it's exactly what you think you're worth
it's a hard thing to accept but in our
lives
we are getting out of our life right now
exactly what we believe we're worthy of
exactly what we think we deserve our
life is a direct reflection
of our identity which is the thoughts
concepts beliefs values and worth we
hold true to be about ourselves
and so as hard as it is to accept we're
getting out of life right now what we
believe we're worth
and we believe we're worth it because of
these patterns and our identity
and our lack of choosing to have what we
want not just the material things
not just the body fat not just the body
weight not just
the amount of money not just having the
relationship but
choosing the emotion we want the level
above all this stuff i discuss
and the level way down here where the
people just cover the basic stuff then
there's what i've been covering
the highest level is to choose the
emotions we want to experience
and to begin to run patterns that serve
us and eliminate the ones who move us
further from them
the final thing i want you to ask
yourself today is we're talking a lot
about these choices
i want you to evaluate for a second what
these patterns are you're running
and when they begin to rear their head
just identify them and begin to make
decisions and choices that create a new
pattern
it's as simple as it is it's not that
complicated you've fallen into these
patterns because there's a payoff
and so as long as you begin to identify
it when it's happening and you begin to
create a new pattern that
leads you to the choice you've chosen
which is the emotion you want
see because these patterns you run that
don't get you there the minute you
choose the emotion you want
you you're conscious about it and
intentional you can't run this pattern
once you identify it and the power of
choice is critical in our lives
see i accepted a long time ago i wasn't
the smartest
the best looking the fast enough with
the best background the most connections
i didn't have any of those things what i
could control was my work ethic
you've heard me speak many times about
outworking everybody
but i think that just feels good when we
hear it but most people don't take it
seriously
if you think that i have a little bit of
success in my life i can tell you what i
attribute it to
yes self-confidence yes mindset
visualization goals
all the things i talk about all the time
listening skills influence energy
transfer
how to be happier all of that stuff
applies when you get to winning
for me it's come down to maxing out and
what maxing out means is
you do one more at least than you think
you're capable of
so when you're done whatever you're
doing whether it's at the gym or
phone calls or meetings or in sports one
more shot one more throw one more swing
of the golf club or the baseball bat
the separator is for the winners they do
one more
i'm addicted to one more and so i want
your mantra going forward to be
one more what are you doing to
intentionally create bliss
in the lives of the people that you care
about because this is the pathway to
getting more of it ourselves the more we
begin to give other people bliss
the more we begin to consciously make
choices that give bliss to other people
in their lives
the more we begin to experience in
abundance ourselves so what are you
doing to help other people win
other people contribute other people get
significance and recognition
other people have more peace and ecstasy
and joy
and passion in their lives because once
you begin to create it for other people
when you're intentional about it
you'll have more of it yourself these
are the patterns that i'd like to see
kick in for you
that when they kick in you begin to run
a pattern in a program that leads you to
bliss
leads you to a win leads you to increase
and also
leads to it with someone in your life
that if you do have a conflict with
somebody
that you run a pattern that eventually
leads maybe it's
understanding them maybe it's
confronting them maybe it's talking
about it
it's not always when you're in a
disagreement that you lead to a win
that you must win this that you must
overcome the fact that they think this
view what if you were consciously
choosing
every time you got into a disagreement
with your spouse this will eventually
lead to more bliss
at least that was your outcome now the
steps you take
it's probably going to be ugly in the
beginning you're probably gonna have to
some understanding
you may not even agree on everything but
if your intention is that it leads to
bliss
rather than you winning rather than you
controlling them rather than you making
it go away
rather than you running a pattern if
when you're beginning to succeed in
business if your
outcome is more bliss more winning
you'll run a pattern that does more of
that
you know squirrels can't find 74 percent
of the nuts they hide
that a fun fact or what why does that
matter because you've been burying your
dreams all your damn life
and guess what you keep thinking you're
waiting for the right time
when winter comes you go find your
little acorns right you think you're
going to find them
let me tell you something you keep
burying those dreams the longer you wait
the harder they are to find
it's time you dig those things out right
now and find them and put them right in
front of you again
and go chase them you can have a great
family and a great business
and a great financial situation and feel
great about yourself and travel the
world and do whatever the heck it is you
want but you need to dig those dreams
out
right now what you allow is what's going
to continue in your life
i put out a post about this several
weeks ago it's hard to accept this but
what's happening in our lives we're
allowing it to happen
and to some extent we almost believe we
deserve it because we produce in our
life
what we really believe we're worth what
we really believe we deserve and it
doesn't
it's hard to accept that because it
seems coincidental you know that the
wrong person entered a life or there was
a business setback or our car broke down
or you know our company went out of
business or whatever it might be one of
your clients just quit and change their
mind
and it seems coincidental but you really
truly are getting out of your life when
you believe you're worth
what you believe you deserve and you're
allowing it to happen and i'm going to
challenge you today to stop that stop
allowing it
and know that you deserve better i want
you to remember something
comparison is the pathway to unhappiness
i'm telling you that in every area of
your life where you find unhappiness you
will find comparison
in fact the antithesis to that is also
true
when there is no comparison you cannot
create unhappiness in your life
that's a pretty bold and powerful
statement but it's true we only feel
unhappy in our lives when we compare
something to maybe something in our life
that was a different time maybe perhaps
when we were wealthier
or in a different relationship or we
were healthier in some level
comparing our current conditions to
previous ones that comparison is what
creates the unhappiness that's actually
not the condition
itself or perhaps you're in a
relationship where you compare it to a
previous relationship you had
and how they treated or how you felt at
that time perhaps you compare this time
in your life just to a simply a
different time
and that comparison will always create
unhappiness in your life
if you can remove yourself from
comparing both yourself to a previous
time in your life a previous condition a
previous situation
or even comparing yourself to other
people in your life
this is a recipe and a formula for
unhappiness
every single time in your life where
you're experiencing unhappiness
you are doing a comparison to something
it's the contradiction between your
current situation
current relationship current body
current finances
current anything and something exterior
either a previous time in your life a
previous person in your life
or you comparing yours to someone else's
it is an insidious disease that so many
people in society suffer from today
particularly because of the advent of
social media
we watch someone's video of what they're
doing on a friday night and it's not
what they're doing that makes us unhappy
it's comparing what they're doing to
what we're doing the people in life
listen to me the people in life that win
play offense not defense
stop backing into everything stand up
bow your back a little bit
start to walk a little different start
to be that best version of you
you can do it in your quiet way you can
do it the way you do it but somehow they
got to look at you and go okay i won't
monkey with that one
okay you read a competitor you recruit
them you get fail you go get another
recruit
ask yourself truthfully your big goals
and dreams are you really clear on what
they are
because if you don't have that we can't
even get started but assuming you've
listened to all of my previous content
before
you know how mandatory it is to be clear
and specific for what you want right
but then the next layer is this can you
get laser obsessively focused
almost to its exclusivity almost
but for an extended period of time can
you honestly say you've done that
for an extended period i'm talking about
a year two years
three years four years five years even a
decade
towards something you want so badly you
want it like oxygen it's like you want
it like you want to eat
you want it like you want to live right
well are you
extendedly laser focused on it or do you
get distracted easily
i'm addicted to one more and so i want
your mantra going forward to be
one more what does that look like if
we're working out that means when we're
in the gym
and we say i'm gonna do five sets of ten
i'm crazy like i'm a psycho because i
wanna win i wanna be somebody i wanna
separate
i wanna compete and the way i do that
isn't with my giftedness because i
wasn't born with a bunch of gifts and i
think
gifts are crap i think for the most part
gifted people struggle in life
because things come easy them i like
that things haven't come easy for me in
my life
i like to have natural talents in every
area and maybe you like that about you
too maybe you've looked at yourself all
your life and thought
man i don't have that natural beauty or
that natural talent or
this gift for creativity or intellect or
humor
i don't have any of those things but
what i got is i will outwork you
and so at the gym one of the things i
focus on they say it's five sets of ten
when i'm at 10 i go one more bam 11.
if i'm running on the treadmill and it's
a 45 minute run i never finish at 45 i
always go one more minute 46.
if i'm at the office and i'm supposed to
make 25 phone calls that day
when i'm at the end of the day i always
do one more
if i've got meetings i always do one
more my mantra for three decades
in business has been one more let's talk
first of all about getting laser focused
and i mean this is your friend
i mean it's talking to myself too i
always cover things that make me better
things that i struggle with but i to
tell you
i think there's a different level for
you i mean i think there's a different
level for you to get obsessed crazy
laser focused i say all the time
our obsessions become our possessions
but we won't possess them if we're not
truly obsessed i bet there's been a
person in your life you've been obsessed
with
if you're over 20 years old listen to
this more than likely you've had
somebody you were pretty obsessed with
haven't you that you wanted in your life
you wanted to date you wanted as a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or a
significant other
how many times a day do you think about
them how many times a day did they
distract you from what you were doing
with just the thought of them
in other words this is what i want you
to understand when you're laser obsessed
focused
your obsession distracts you from what
you're currently doing not the other way
around
you're not really obsessed with it if
you're easily distracted
from it this is so important you right
now can test whether it's your obsession
with whether it distracts you constantly
the first thing you think of when you
wake up
last thing before you go to bed when you
have a big laugh it comes up when you
cry it comes up when you're watching tv
it comes up
when you're doing your regular job but
it's your side hustle it comes up you
can't stop thinking about it
it distracts you from the rest of your
life that's what an obsession does
when it's not really your obsession the
rest of your life distracts you from it
and so the it in your life is so
important but there's all these things
that distract us today i'm gonna give
you a recommendation turn your damn tv
off
turn the radio off most of the time turn
your phone off a lot too
you gotta rise up you gotta make your
dreams a reality and live a damn
masterpiece you know this now here's the
thing a couple things
you got to make a decision listen to me
you got to make a decision what's the
decision
what's the thing you came here for now
we're at the moment
the clock is ticking people say all the
time hey life is short
let me tell you something life can be
long
you bury your dreams you quit this life
gets long
see time's relative two minutes of you
being with your sweetie doing whatever
you like to do with them
that can go by quick right what about
the last two minutes on a treadmill does
that not seem like it goes by for like
four hours right
so if you're enjoying it it's short if
it's painful it's long
life can be long you want a life that
feels like it's flying by you want a
life like i have right now where i go
can i just press
pause can i just press pause it's so
good it's so great
it's so rewarding it's so awesome but i
don't really want to press pause because
i know it can get better
so what's the decision what have you
been sitting on what is it
is it people are texting me hey ed i
submitted my resignation last night i'm
coming full time i walked away from a
six-figure job is that the decision
is it the decision to finally get
serious is the decision to get licensed
is the decision to stop worrying about
what people think is the decision to
become a great closer
is the decision of something in a
relationship you have you need to get
out or
into it's only a thought if you don't
take an action
the difference between a thought and a
decision there's an action so we know
and you know you just decided and you
know what it is
you know what it is
you will have really decided within this
next hour you took
some step towards it something
a note you write a text you send a
decision you've made
something you do that you follow up with
the action to make it real
it's not the success of people you know
that's making you unhappy
it's your comparing your situation to
the success they're having
that creates unhappiness in your life so
for those of you that are struggling and
saying you know one of the things i
suffer from is i'm just not very happy
very often
i can tell you that that presence of
unhappiness
you will always link to a comparison of
some sort
either in your own life or in other
people's lives and just being aware of
that fact and
stopping the comparison embracing this
moment embracing this time
knowing that you can't go back to that
previous time knowing that you can't be
in somebody else's life
you're not gonna have that other body
right now and so if you're looking to be
happier i can promise you
the number one key that i would give you
is to stop the comparison game
you'd say well that's not completely
true i mean what if someone passes away
that makes me unhappy there's no
comparison there let's take the most
extreme example
or when someone's sick in my family uh
you know
someone in my family's got a really bad
illness that makes me unhappy that's not
a comparison in fact it is
the fact of the matter is that when
someone gets sick in your family or
passes away what you do in your mind is
you compare it
to when they were healthy so that
comparison of i wish they were healthier
again that is a comparison between the
previous situation
and the current condition if someone
passes away it's comparing
the time that you had them that's why
people say if i could just have one more
moment with them
if i could just have another
conversation it's comparing it to when
you had the moment it's comparing it
to when you had the conversation and so
those are extreme examples
but if we reduce it all the way down to
anything right now in your life that you
say it brings me unhappiness there's no
joy there
there's a comparison happening that's
not serving you lack of belief
it'll steal your dream you got to know
you're going to win
you've got to have some faith these
people sitting around you right now
they're whispering to you you could do
this i believe you just like when you
were a little boy
just like when you were a little girl
they've always believed in you they've
always known you're going to do
something special they always knew you
were great
you need to know it you need to take
that god that's sitting there with you
and those precious souls that have
passed that have always believed in you
and you carry them with you everywhere
they're with you
anyway acknowledge them if you don't
believe that
honor them honor god honor these people
who believed in you
with your magnificent life honor them
don't give in to lack of belief lack of
confidence don't ever do that again
don't do it in wfg or out of wfg you
were made to do something great
you're special you were made in the
image of god something awesome supposed
to happen for you
and those of you that have made
something awesome happen something even
more awesome supposed to happen for you
don't compare yourself most the people
you see on social media or even in your
personal life or even when you go to
lunch with them or see them at work
they're wearing what i would call a
public mask it's the best possible
version
that they can put out to themselves and
oftentimes what we do in life is
we compare our real identity that we're
working on and we're growing
to their mask and that's not fair to
ourselves at all
any comparison doesn't serve us and it's
oftentimes this comparison
when you're in a disagreement with
somebody it's the mask they're wearing
compared to the identity you have and
then you begin to run a pattern to
respond to it
it happens in in fitness in
relationships in money and in business
remember you're in charge of controlling
your own identity
and growing your own identity and being
aware of the patterns you have that do
and do not serve you
not comparing yourself to someone else's
public representative
it's just the representative they're
putting out there it's not who they
really are
and it's not something that you need to
be aware of because it's not something
you can control
the more you can begin to delineate in
life between things i can control
and i cannot control would be to the
extent that you're more productive and
you're happier
you can control your own thoughts your
own emotions
your own identity and your own patterns
not other people human beings that get
obsessed and immersed in any topic
can become great at it and so can you so
pick what you want and get laser focused
begin to eliminate all the distractions
you are not hungry enough
you are not starving enough and you are
not focused enough i say this to you as
a friend
what are the things that are stealing
your focus who are the people that are
stealing your focus
and begin to eliminate these
distractions get laser focused and
obsessed on what you want
be starving and hungry to get it be
desperate to get it
the combination of desperation and
hunger
with laser focus over an extended period
of time
is the formula to be great at something
and you can apply this formula get laser
focused
eliminate distractions eliminate the
things that steal
your laser focused on it your research
on it your obsession on it
begin to do these things and you will
begin to change your entire life
and the power of choice is critical in
our lives i want you to think about
something right now
what are five of the most important
choices you've made in your life
just think about that for a second begin
to list them off in your head
five of the most important choices
you've made in your life
maybe it was a decision to get involved
in a particular business
or to leave a particular business maybe
it was a decision to get involved with a
particular person
or to become uninvolved with a
particular person
maybe it was a friend but you chose to
walk across the room and meet and it
changed your life
maybe it was a friend that you had to
walk away from in order to improve your
life
what are the five most important choices
of your life
just think about them for a second and
if you altered those five
choices good bad or indifferent how
different would your life be today
because i'm a believer that there's
everyday choices we make
that when you stack them up they make a
massive difference in our life
but i'm also a believer that there are
between five and ten a handful of
moments in everybody's life
that if we make the proper choices in
those moments the complete trajectory of
our life changes
and i think as you just asked yourself
that question you may say there haven't
been five there's been two
what were they and how they alter the
direction of your life if you meet
people that you think are egomaniacs
that are consciously bragging about
themselves these are the most insecure
people that you know
they're the most fearful people that you
know they're the most scared and they're
usually the least happy
and so but i'm gonna say something to
you i want you to consider as i go
through ego today
i know you think wow i'm so down on
myself how could i have an ego it's
actually the people that are down
on themselves that actually have their
ego materialized and show up more often
than they think
and it's their ego that may actually be
holding them back you think wow
how could someone with low self-esteem
have a big ego well trust me they do
and so egos are not part of people with
high self-esteem
the people in my life that are the most
self-confident
typically don't have big egos if you
have to wait around for other people to
tell you hey your ego's out of control
it's too late usually so we've got to be
able to see our ego when it rears its
head be aware of it and it loses its
power over us we can go back to being
our real selves
you can't love yourself if you're not
being yourself
you can't love yourself if you're not
being yourself but remember this when
ego shows up we're not ourselves
we're not connected to god in other
words if you can let go of your ego you
can let god in when you can let go of
your ego you can let your real
confidence in
when you let go of your ego you can go
really become who you were born to be
and so oftentimes this is so important
you get
you may be losing right now because of
your ego
because of your ego because you're not
feeling good about yourself well i think
the thing that
holds most people back is their identity
and so i'm pretty good at getting people
to change their identity in other words
your identity is the thoughts concepts
beliefs
values that you hold to be true about
yourself and your life is going to be
very consistent with that your identity
is
for the most part in the room right next
to me i can see it but you can't there's
a thermostat sitting on the wall in
there
that thermostat regulates the
temperature of the room
it's set at 75 degrees so right now i
opened up the doors it's a cold rainy
day here i live right on the ocean
a bunch of cold air is blowing in here
right now but the room's not going to
cool down to the external conditions the
room is going to heat back up to 75
degrees because that thermostat
will keep the room up to get it to the
temperature it's set at
its identity if i open that door and hot
air blew in here which probably is now
that i'm starting to talk
the air conditioner will turn on and
cool that room back to 75 degrees it
regulates the temperature
your identity regulates the temperature
of your life
no matter what happens the external
conditions can get better and better and
better you're making more money or
you're more fit or you're in a better
relationship
but if you don't change your identity
it's if you're a 75 degree
and you're getting 85 90 95 degrees of
results you'll find a way over a pretty
short period of time to turn the air
conditioner back down
and get those areas right back to what
your identity is and that's why you'll
see
people get ahead and then come back lose
weight and gain it get a great
relationship and lose it make a bunch of
money and get back
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you my dad's
a tough dude
my dad was a hockey player when i was a
little boy
i was little eddie i'm eddie the third
by the way my grandfather's edward my
dad's edward i'm edward so i was little
eddie eddie the third
kids at school called me eddie spaghetti
that wasn't fun
say eddie spaghetti your meatballs are
ready that's what they would say
that's how they tease me and the
the jerk that started this lived right
next door to me
little ray ray this little punk
so there's little eddie and there's
ray-ray why is he ray-ray cause his
dad's big ray
[Music]
we lived in weymouth massachusetts at
the time
they're woo him but they wouldn't want
to retire there let's put it that way
that is not laguna beach is it everybody
so my house my my house is the same
exact house as ray race
except you know how track houses are
they just flip them so it's his house my
house in reverse
so we shared a driveway their porch
their stairs to their house was here
mine was there so when they're eating
dinner i could hear all their
conversations they could hear all
ours and ray ray's the one who started
eddie spaghetti your meatballs are ready
and i didn't like it and he used to kind
of mess with me he figured out i was
kind of soft you know you kind of
figured out like
we're playing football on the street he
kind of whacked me and i wouldn't whack
him back
you know those kind of things little
kids do to figure it out he was the stud
i was the weak kid and he figured it out
he was big i was little eddie
literally little eddie really small
and so ray ray used to kind of slap me
around a little bit and one day we got a
little scrape
behind the cars in the driveway and ray
ray
kicked my ass pretty good pretty damn
good
to the point where i ran away from him
crying
maybe you can relate to this and i ran
into the house and my mom was on the
porch
oh my gosh what happened mama reaped he
slammed he punched me in the face
oh come here sweetheart i remember come
here baby we're in the kitchen and
she's hugging me it's okay he's a bad
boy his daddy's been in jail like three
times
we're just we're not that kind of family
they're mean right he's a bad man
i go mommy he's a bad man they're bad
people
and i can hear i can hear
here comes big head down the hallway i
can hear him i'm thinking he's going to
give me a big hug too right my dick
what the hell is going on in here
my mom turns around and says this
criminal next door ray ray has assaulted
our son for the 400th time that's what's
going on here
are you going to do anything about this
and my dad goes
get your hands off him he goes get over
here
and he gets down at my level and he goes
look at me
you are leaving this house and you are
going back
over there and you are kicking his ass
you understand me
no dad he always kicks my mind
he said you don't come back in this
house until you kick his ass you
understand me
my mom ed what are you doing debbie stop
it i know what i'm doing here
don't come back here till you beat him
up you understand me
huh oh okay daddy
and i walk out of the door and i walk
over to their porch which is like three
steps from ours
and my dad's behind the screen i see him
in the kitchen behind our screen with my
mom
my mom's crying my dad's like i got this
right and i knock on the door
their screen and big ray all tatted up
no shirt on
he's through the street what's up eddie
i said um
big ray um my dad says i have to come
over here
and kick ray ray's ass or i can't come
home for dinner
so and b-ray goes i like that kind of
party let's get him
i'm serious
i hear him at the door right right right
right that's all you're doing right
right
get over here little ray little bulldog
comes running up
[Music]
right he goes hey little eddie wants
another piece
and ray ray goes let's do this i'm like
oh crap
and we're walking down his stairs and i
can see my dad in the screen over here
i'm like oh my god and i'll never forget
this the two cars were there my dad's
datsun b210
orange hashback and his dad's green
pinto flanked our estates right there in
the driveway
oil all over the driveway because big
ray would change everything in the
driveway
and we got up there and big ray goes you
get there you get there
go and ray ray came at me and by some
force of
sheer blessing from god i got this
little dude in a headlock and i'm giving
him my dad used to give me noogies
remember noogies
so i don't really know how to hit him
but i'm nooging the hell out of this
kid's head
[Applause]
there's nuggies i'm ripping the hair off
his damn head and i'm choking him
noogies i'm kind of looking back at the
screen and see my daddy i got him dad
i got him dad and so finally i'm noogie
and this kid that death
literally can't breathe and so finally
ray's go get him right get him right i'm
hearing him go get him right
i'm like look he's i won't let him go
he's trying to squirm and i'm like
i'm kind of slapping him in the head
these little boys out there right
and so finally i kicked his ass right
no so
big ray stops it big ray pulls us off
each other and he goes
ray ray he got you now shake his hand
and we shook hands and i walked home my
dad's night now get in here let's make
some spaghetti let's do this right
right so proud of me
so now now i'm just going to tell you a
couple couple things you need to know
number one that top me life will give
you what you'll fight for
that's really the point of the story now
my mother who heard me tell this story
one of the times
she feels like i should also divulge
another set of facts i don't even know
why this is relevant at all
but because my mom asked you i will just
because this was the
i'll just tell you i was seven ray ray
was four i just want you to know that
but i don't know why that's even
relevant
why is that relevant
why is that relevant
for real
that's true little seven-year-old
kicking a four-year-old's butt with
noogies
in the driveway but hey listen to me
you all got some ray rays in your life
stuff you make much bigger and more
difficult and more powerful than it is
that could defeat you
in hindsight i was damned seven years
old this kid was practically in diapers
still
of course i could kick his butt right so
hey
maybe you can relate to that you got
something in your life like that
all right mom you see this on youtube i
did tell the truth this time so just so
you know
if you want some amazing motivation from
robin sharma check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there but as we leave the perfection of
childhood
the hypnosis and the brainwashing begins
our well-intentioned parents say
oh you want to be an astronaut you want
to start a business
when you grow up